foreign
we are stepping into 2023 students
College grads and professionals are
actively looking for a brighter career
and Brilliant career transition into
software development yet there's one
question that needs to be answered which
programming language to choose the
answer is Java Java is the only
programming language that spread its
roots into almost everything from
designing software to the entire
software development framework from
designing a database to a complete Cloud
platform from a simple mobile
application to a fully fresh operating
system Java is everywhere what better
than choosing a Triad tested and well
established programming language you are
already watching simply learn and we
bring you the complete core Java course
in the core Java tutorial you will learn
the following a brief introduction to
Java where you learn a brief history and
the fundamentals of Java programming
that covers data types variables loops
and conditional statements post that you
will learn to to develop your first Java
program once you understand the basics
better we can escalate to the next level
where you will learn data structures in
Java post that you will learn the Java
Collections
finally you learn the object oriented
paradigms in Java where you will be
introduced to abstraction encapsulation
inheritance and polymorphism in Java
throughout this session the programming
technicalities will be covered in
theoretical and practical ways to
deliver the best learning experience now
over to our training experts hello guys
this is vikesh and let's get started
with the first topic of this series
which is about introduction to Java so
when we talk about Java it is one of the
most popular programming language out
there and it was created way back in
1991 but it was publicly released only
in 1995. it was developed by one of the
famous developers of Our Generation who
is James Gosling at Sun Microsystems and
then later Java was acquired by Oracle
and today Oracle owns Java Java is very
simple and easy to use and we will look
at different and aspects of how it is
easy and simple to use it's a right once
Run Anywhere type of programming
language again we will look at details
into into into this particular concept
as well and when we talk about the usage
of java you can use it to build web
applications mobile applications desktop
applications even command line
applications and at the same time you
can also use it to build complex
applications like gaming applications
building microservices or building
distributed computing Etc let's talk
about the features of java so one of the
most prominent features of java is that
it's an object oriented programming
language which means that everything
which happens in Java happens around
objects objects enable the execution of
the program objects talk to each other
to exchange data and messages we will
look a look at the concept of objects in
details in the upcoming lectures it's a
platform independent language which
means that uh again going back to the
previous point of write once Run
Anywhere it basically enables the
program to be run on any platform once
compiled so once you have prepared your
program and you have compiled your
program then your compiled program can
be run on any platform it is a strong
type checking language which means that
it will force you to respect the
contracts of the variables to the data
types for example if you have created a
collection which should accept strings
then you can only insert strings in that
collection and it will not allow you to
add an a number or an integer into that
collection so it's a strongly typed
checking language so when you run your
program it's a two-step process in Java
you compile the program and then you it
then you execute the program which we
also call as interpretation so you have
a Java compiler and you have a Java
interpreter you first compile your
program and then you run the program
using the help of java interpreter Java
also provides automatic garbage
collection it's a really important
feature and if you talk about the
languages prior to Java like C or C plus
plus they did not offer this capability
and this capability made Java really
popular because it could automatically
find the unused objects and variables
and remove them from the memory to free
up memory space for the program
execution it also provides
multi-threading support which means that
you can build multi-threading
applications like a gaming application
if you take the example of a racing game
for example so there's they can be one
thread which is monitoring your
leaderboard score there can be another
thread which is displaying the speed of
the car there can be another thread
which is displaying the graphic there
can be another thread which is
displaying the sound so you see all of
these threads are working parallely and
Java provides the support to create such
applications using the multi-threading
capability it has Java is secure by
default because there are no pointers in
Java so there are no possibilities of
having any memory leaks or any reference
leaks from the application again if you
take the example of programming
languages like C or C plus plus you had
the concept of pointers and we we
witnessed lot of a lot of scenarios and
lot of incidents where there was a
memory leakage happening in the in the
production application which was which
was really a bad experience for the
organizations so Java removed the
concept of pointers totally from its
programming language it's also a very
robust language because it provides a
really great exception handling
framework out of the box which
developers can use and Implement to
build really resilient applications so
now let us understand how a Java program
is run so at first you basically write
your Java program and you store your
Java program into a DOT Java file then
you compile your Java file with the help
of the Java compiler once the program is
compiled the compiler is going to
generate another file which is a DOT
class file and this dot class file is
basically the compiled file or also
known as the byte code file so this byte
code or the dot class file code can be
run on any platform be it a Linux
platform or a Windows platform or a Mac
OS platform or any other platform to
give you some more context the first two
steps where you write your Java program
and you compile your Java program can be
run on any machine let's take the
example that you ran these two steps on
a Windows machine so you run your you
write your program and you compile your
program on a Windows machine which
generated a DOT class file then you
transported this dot class file to a
Linux machine and it also worked there
you transported your dot class file to a
Mac OS machine and it worked there as
well and that's what brings the platform
independent dependence concept of java
that you can write the program once on
any platform and once you have the byte
code available then you can run this
program on any other platform of your
choice okay so that was about how the
Java program execution works and how the
platform Independence is actually
achieved now let us spend some time to
understand the anatomy of java so once
you download Java and install Java on
your local machine you will hear the
term jdk actually if you will see that
in the next lecture that when you try to
download the Java it will say jdk
download jdk stands for Java development
kit so the Java development kit is the
installation of the Java this is what
you're going to install on your machine
once the jdk or Java development kit has
been installed the jdk will provide lot
of other components as well like Java
runtime environment or JRE Java virtual
machine or jvm some class libraries and
some other supporting libraries so let
us understand what happens when your
program is run and how these components
work together to make sure that your
program runs as expected let's start
from here so you install jdk or the Java
development kit you write your program
and then you compile your program with
the help of java compiler which is
provided by jdk once the program is
compiled your dot class file will be
generated and then you can run
that.class file using GRE in fact if you
just run your program on your local
machine JRE will automatically kick in
and run your dot class file so the Java
runtime environment or GRE runs your dot
class file with the help of these three
components let's talk about first
component which is Java virtual machine
or jvm so the Java virtual machine is
actually the virtual Envy environment
inside which your program runs this is
the real main environment inside your
dot class file is running so when when
this program is running how does it
achieve this environment for achieving
this virtual virtual machine environment
it would need some runtime libraries and
that is provided by these class
libraries for example there would be a
runtime jar or rt.jar as a shorthand
which will be supplied to the program at
the runtime to make sure that the
program runs smoothly then there are
other supporting libraries as well which
your program may be using for example if
this program this dot class file is
let's say a calculator program then it
might be using a square root function
from java.math package so how do how
does the java.net package gets supplied
at runtime it would be supplied by the
other supporting libraries which are
present inside GRE so GRE will make sure
that your program runs inside the Java
virtual machine it gets the required
runtime libraries and it also gets the
libraries which are referred in your
program at runtime and this all together
will make sure that your program is
running so you can see jdk basically
provides GRE automatically and jvm
automatically but you can also install
GRE separately if you talk about that
use case where you compile your program
on a Windows machine using jdk and then
you exported your dot class file to
another machine and there you just
install the GRE you don't install jdk
there you just install the runtime
environment and you can run the dot
class file just using the runtime
environment and that brings us to the
end of this lecture let's get started
with installing Java we will basically
look at how we can install Java on a
Windows machine so the first step to
install Java is to download it from the
official Oracle website so for that
let's open a web browser and let's type
jdk Java download and hit enter then you
need to find the link which says
oracle.com because like we discussed in
the previous lecture uh Java is owned by
Oracle so we need to download it from
the official website only so we can
click on this link which says Java SE
downloads it will bring us to the
downloads page and we will see different
versions of java you can see the Java
se15 you can see Java se14 you can also
see Java se11 and all the previous
versions another thing which you will
notice that it says LTS here which means
long term support basically long term
support are the releases for which
Oracle is going to provide long-term
security patches and updates for the
non-lts releases Java will not provide
long-term support and long-term patch
fixes and long-term security fixes so
it's a good idea to analyze and evaluate
on which version you want to develop
your applications on for this demo I
think it is fine we can go with the
non-lts version and even for your for
your customer facing applications you
can start with the non-lts version and
then upgrade to the latest LPS version
whenever that is available so for this
demo we can download Java se15 and you
can also do the same on your machine it
will work exactly the same way as an LTS
works so you can click on the jdk
download option here let's click on that
it is going to bring up the downloads
detail page and you can see there are
multiple options given here in terms of
what platform you want to install Java
on whether it is a Linux platform or it
is a Mac OS machine or it is a Windows
platform so like I said in the beginning
of the demo that today we are going to
see how we can install this on a Windows
machine so I'm going to download the
windows x64 installer here if you are
working on a Linux machine or a Mac OS
machine you can download those
respective installers as well so you can
see the exe here so let's click on this
once we click on this we'll get this
pop-up which will ask us to accept the
Oracle technology Network license
agreement so we can hit this checkbox
and click on download jdk 15 and this
shall start the download and you will
see some some exe getting downloaded in
in your download box here but as the
download is going to take some time and
I'm not going to wait for that and
that's the reason I have already
downloaded the jdk 15 for this
particular demo and that jdk is is
sitting here on my desktop which I have
downloaded prior to this demo so we'll
just run this particular exe which is
exactly the same exe as the one which is
being downloaded so let us double click
on this it will ask you for this pop-up
in some cases so you can just hit yes
basically it is asking whether you trust
this exe or not but as we downloaded
this from official Oracle website then
we can trust this particular exe so I
will hit yes and now the installer is
going to unpack and you might get a
screen like this which will be an
installation wizard for the Java SC
development kit 15. another thing which
before I proceed I just wanted to
highlight that as well that you might
have noticed the word jdk here it's
exactly the same term which we covered
in the last lecture that when you
install Java you basically install the
jdk which is the Java development kit
and this is also visible here when it
says Java SC development kit 15. so
let's hit next then on this particular
page you have the option to change the
installation location of java if you
want to by default it is going to
install in C program files slash Java
slash jdk15 but if you want to change
the location and you want to install
Java to a particular custom location of
your choice that is also possible you
just hit change here and then you can
choose whatever directory or folder or
place you want to install this Java on
and you can basically select the
appropriate location for this particular
case I don't want to change that I'm
happy with the default location which is
available here so I'm just going to
proceed with this particular location
here so I will just hit next and then
Java is going to install and it's it's
very fast installation it generally
takes few seconds as you will see in
this demo basically it is going to
unpack all the all the libraries and all
the runtime libraries and all the class
path libraries which we discussed in the
previous lecture and put all that into
the location which we specified to
install Java it will also set up the
rest of the prerequisites which are
required to run Java successfully so
looks like the Java has been
successfully installed as is visible in
this message and there's also a next
step if you want to access the tutorials
or the API documentations the developer
guides the release notes Etc I don't
want to do that so I will just hit close
here and now if we want to just verify
if Java is is installed or not then we
can verify that from the command and
prompt let me just exit this and let's
go to the command prompt to verify to
see if Java has been successfully
installed so to do that uh we'll we'll
just open the search bar and we'll type
CMD it is going to show us this command
prompt here we'll click on this and it
will open the command prompt for you
like it has opened for me and there you
just need to type Java hyphen version
and you hit enter if you get a message
like this it means Java has been
successfully installed if you get a
message saying that Java is not
recognized as a command it means that
Java is still not successfully installed
and something has gone wrong in your
installation and in that case you might
want to restart you might want to go
back and reinstall this Java exe again
so in this case it looks like it has
been successfully installed and we can
also get some interesting information
from here we can see which version of
java has been installed it says Java
version 15. we can also see that the JRE
is also installed the Java SC runtime
environment what JRE is also installed
and we can also see that the jvm is also
installed which is Java hotspot server
VM VM means the virtual machine so if I
connect this back to the previous
lecture we can see that the Java jdk
basically installed the JRE as well as
the jvm as well and the complete Java
package has been successfully installed
now we are ready to use Java a Java
program and run Java programs on this
machine and at this step I would like to
conclude this lecture in the next
session we will be discussing how we can
install Eclipse because that would be
the natural next step for any Java
developer that they want to install Java
line then they want to install eclipse
and start working let's get started with
installing eclipse on a Windows machine
so the first thing which we need to do
is to download Eclipse so for that I'm
just going to open my web browser and
type Eclipse download press enter and
then you need to find the link which
says eclipse.org downloads which is the
first link in my search results you can
also see it says Eclipse downloads the
eclipse Foundation an eclipse Foundation
is the is the organization which
maintains the eclipse installers so we
can click on this once we click on this
we will be redirected onto the eclipse
downloads page and there again you will
see bunch of options you will see the
default option highlighted which would
be the eclipse installer for uh for GRE
for Mac OS windows and Linux and then
you have some other tool platforms
option as well like eclipse she or Orion
which you might want to use for advanced
cases but for running Java applications
all you need is an eclipse installer
which is coming from here so based on
your machine Eclipse will automatically
detect whether you want a 64-bit
installer or a 32-bit installer and you
can just click on this particular link
which says download 64-bit here so I'm
just going to hit download 64-bit it is
going to open this particular screen
where based on your current location
Eclipse will suggest the nearest
possible distribution mirror
distribution mirror is basically a
server which is present somewhere in
this world which contains this Eclipse
installer exe and Eclipse has created
these servers all across the Globes
these servers are basically called the
mirrors and based on your current
location which will be deducted taken
taken from your ISP from the internet IP
address from which you are accessing
this particular website so based on your
ISP location it is going to suggest you
the nearest possible mirror location so
that your download is the fastest so in
my case the nearest location is
Netherlands here as you can see and I
get a download option this is the file
name which says Eclipse installer JRE
windows 64.exe and if you think that
this mirror doesn't make sense just
click on this option select another
mirror and then you can choose another
mirror but generally it works really
well it works based on it works based on
your IP location and it's generally the
download speed is pretty good based on
the suggested mirror so I'm not going to
change the mirror location because I
think this works fine for me so and I'm
just going to click on this particular
button which is going to start the
download of the eclipse installer so now
I have I have hit the download button
and you can see right now and exe has
been download has begun to download uh
it is going to again take some time and
I have already downloaded this
particular exe just to save us some time
and I'm going to use that exe to
Showcase how we can install it another
thing just wanted to highlight is that
eclipse is an open source organization
it works on donations so if you feel
generous about it and if you feel that
eclipse is doing really great work you
can also donate to it which will show
here so we can move to the next step
which is about installing so you can see
here I have an installer here an exe
file basically which I have
pre-downloaded to Showcase this demo I'm
just going to double click on this and
it is going to unpack the installer you
can see this this icon will be presented
to you which says Eclipse installer by
oomph oomph is basically the provider
for this particular installer who
manages the installer and based on your
computer's capacity and speed it is
going to take few seconds and in the
background what it is doing is basically
it is unpacking this installer and
creating all the installation files
which it needs to success fully install
it on your computer once that is done
you will be presented with this kind of
screen and you will see that Eclipse
provides multiple different kind of Ides
for different set of developer
communities you will see an option which
says Eclipse IDE for Java developers you
will also see Eclipse IDE for Enterprise
Java developers you will see the IDE for
C plus plus and C developers web and
JavaScript PHP Eclipse committers who
basically contribute to the eclipse
organization or RCP rap tester
scientific Computing there are tons of
Ides which Eclipse maintains for our use
case throughout this series I think we
will be focusing on this particular IDE
which says Eclipse IDE for Enterprise
Java developers you can also use this
particular IDE but this is a very bare
bone IDE with very limited set of
Integrations like it says it includes a
Java IDE a git client an XML editor a
maven plugin and a Gradle plugin but if
you look at the Enterprise you will get
more Integrations you can use this
particular IDE to work on whatever you
work here so these all will work here
but in addition you can also use this
IDE to build a web application build a
web service build a jpa application data
tools Java server Pages faces Etc so
this is more a more advanced I would say
and we will go with this particular IDE
and you can also choose this ID if you
want to but for this demo we are going
to choose this one I will click on this
then it is going to show me which
virtual machine it is going to use so if
you remember in the previous lecture we
installed Java 15 it has automatically
detected that location by reading by C
program files folder and it has
automatically taken that if you have
multiple jdk installations on your
machine you can click on this icon and
change a different Java virtual machine
I'm going to leave it as is again the
installation folder is also by default
taken to your C users username slash
eclipse
slash.jee version number and again if
you want to change this you can also
change a different installation folder
I'm going to leave everything as default
it will automatically create a start
menu entry and a desktop shortcut and
now I hit install it might come ask you
for a user agreement so you can hit
accept now and now it has begun the
installation the installation generally
takes a bit of time to complete in some
cases so again it depends upon your in
your in your computer's capacity and the
speed basically if it's a good robust
machine with the with good capacity the
installation might be very fast as you
can see in my computer and if you have a
computer which is not very strong on
configurations you can just be patient
and wait for some time and the
installation will be finished once the
installation is finished you will see
this launch option here you will also
have an option to keep an installer if
you want to show the readme file but I
think the the main option here which we
are going to use is the launch option so
if you you hit the launch option now the
actual IDE is going to start up it's
again going to set up some configuration
files and some bootstrap configuration
files which it needs to and then it will
ask you to choose a workspace again
workspace is up to you where do you
where you want to create your workspace
the workspace is basically the location
where you you will create your projects
it will store those project files and
the source code of those projects so it
is up to you where you want to create it
again I'm going to leave it as default
here but if you want to change it just
hit browse here and choose whatever
location you want to you can see you can
choose you can go to PC and you can
choose whatever location you want to I'm
going to leave it as is and you also
have a choice that you don't want
Eclipse to ask this every time so you
can check this box and next time eclipse
is not going to ask you to choose a
directory as workspace and every time
you start Eclipse it will automatically
go to this particular directory so you
can either check it or uncheck it based
on your convenience
and hit launch once you hit launch it is
going to start the actual IDE there's a
desktop application and you will get a
nice interface and a welcome screen from
Eclipse which will which will basically
show the basic uh overview of the screen
something like this so now you can see
that the eclipse ID has started it has a
welcome page which has multiple options
you can check out a project from Git You
Can import an existing project you can
go to the marketplace create a Java web
project or whatever or you can just
close this you have a nice navigation
project project Explorer bar here so all
the projects which you are going to
create will be listed here there are
also some quick shortcuts here for
creating different kind of projects and
if you don't want to use that just go to
file new and choose a kind of project
you want to create whether it is a maven
project or Enterprise application
project or dynamic web project or just a
project if you just hit just a project
you can choose a basic Java project to
start with click next give a project
name let's call it test demo you can
choose an execution environment here the
GRE and currently this particular ID has
support up to 14 but I think this is
going to work fine we don't need to
worry about it we can also use our
Project Specific GRE like in this case
Java 15 which is the current
installation so I can use this option
because I want to use Java 15
environment because I have Java 15
installed so you can basically choose
whatever option you want to choose it
gives you a flexibility in terms of
choosing the GRE whether you want to
choose an external GRE whether you want
to choose a Project Specific GRE or you
want to use the default GRE jdk
installation so you can use this option
as well if you want to project layout is
create either you want to create
separate folders for source and classes
or you want to create the use the
project folder again this is these are
just basic configurations which you can
play around with if you want to I'm just
going to leave it as is and hit next and
then it is going to just give me a
review screen here if I want to change
anything I can otherwise I can just hit
finish I can create a module name here
if I want to but I don't want to create
it so just hit on don't create and open
the Java perspective and that's it you
have a Java project here where you can
create your Java files under this SRC
and you can start executing those files
we will look out on those details in the
upcoming lectures but for this lecture I
think this is what we wanted to achieve
we wanted to show how we can install
eclipse and how we can create a very
sample uh Java CLI project so this is it
for this in this session in the next
session we will look at some of the data
types in Java let's get started with
primitive data types in Java we are
going to learn about the primitive data
types in Java and we'll also see a short
demonstration of it so let's get started
let's first just learn about those data
types I've just opened the official
Oracle documentation and don't worry if
you see how this link appear years here
you can just open a browser window and
just type Java primitive data types and
if you hit enter the first link which
you will be given is this particular
link and this is the same link which I
have opened so let's learn about the
data types now so Java has these
primitive data types which you can see
here some of them store numbers some of
them store Boolean values and some of
them store characters so the data types
which store numbers are byte short int
long float and double these six data
types basically are used to store any
kind of numeric value let's understand
these a bit more byte is the shortest
possible data type value which you can
use in Java to store numbers you can
only store numbers within the range of
-128 to plus 127 so you can see the
range is very small and Java has created
this variable for use cases where you
want to store numbers which are very
small value in this range why do we
provide these kind of options just to
save memory because the smaller data
type will require less memory to be used
in the Java program similarly the next
big data type is short which is a bit
bigger than byte and the range of this
particular data type where variables
will range from
-3 to 678 to plus
32767 so that is the range for this
particular variable and you can see that
it has a it has a very big range as
compared to the byte data type so if you
want to store very values which lie in
this range you can use short the next
one is int data type you can use this
one to store even larger values which
range from minus 2 raised to power 31 to
plus 2 raised to power 31 minus 1. the
next one is long which is even bigger
than int and it can be used to store the
values within the range of minus minus 2
raised to power 63 to plus 2 raised to
power 63 minus 1. so as you can see as
we go from top to bottom from byte to
Long the size of the value which can be
stored using this data type increases
and that's how you will basically take a
decision of whether you want to use byte
or you want to use short or int or long
based on what size of the value that
variable is going to contain then the
next ones are float and double these two
have been created for the use cases
whether where you want to store the
values numeric values which have
decibels which are Precision values I
should also mention that byte short int
and long are only used for storing
absolute numbers which do not have any
decimal representation even if you try
to store a decimal value in these
variables they will automatically be
trimmed the decimal values will
automatically be removed and you will
only be sure own the absolute values and
in case of float and double they can
maintain those precision and decimal
values so we use float for the use cases
where you want to store decimal
representations of the values and you
can see that the float value can store a
smaller Precision value but double can
store even a bigger Precision value so
if you have really big Precision values
to be maintained very big decimal values
to be maintained we should use double
and the float is used for storing a bit
smaller size of the Precision values I
mean its range of values basically
beyond the scope of this discussion if
you want to read more about this you can
go to this particular links which will
explain this in detail but the basic
idea is that float is good for storing
two Precision values and if you want to
go beyond that you want to use double in
some cases some people also use float to
store even Beyond two values as well so
it completely depends the main the
decision factor is how long the value
you are going to store in the decimal
and that will take the decide whether
you want to use float or double the next
one is Boolean which is used for storing
the Boolean values Boolean values can be
either true or false so there are only
two possible values and then we have
care which is used for storing
characters it is using 16 bit to store
the value and this is a very popular
Java question for beginner level
programmers that why does it store uh
needs 16 bit to store the character it's
because it stores a Unicode
representation Unicode representation is
the representation which can be accepted
across platforms across the world in
different character encodings so let's
move on to Eclipse now where I have
prepared a very short and simple demo I
am just creating a variable for each
data type and I'm printing them you also
see some things here like the these
keywords and don't worry about these
keywords I will cover this keywords in
detail in the upcoming lectures you also
see this and you can just for now you
can remember that system dot out dot
println is used for printing anything in
Java anything you want to print on the
console you would be using
system.out.printellin what is system
what is out and what is println again we
will cover these in the uh upcoming
lectures for now I'm just creating a
bunch of data types here variables here
basically I'm creating a cat type
variable a byte type variable a short
type variable an n-type variable a float
type variable a double and a Boolean the
way you create variables is basically
you put the data type name you put the
variable name which can be anything you
put an equal sign and you put the value
actual value which this variable is
going to store and I've done the similar
thing for all of these variables Java
wants semicolons to be there when you
write your statements so please remember
that your statements always end with
semicolon events so I've declared all of
these variables here a byte a short and
int float double and Boolean and then
I'm printing all of them basically here
I'm printing the care variable here I'm
printing the byte variable here I'm
printing the short and so on so forth so
how do we actually run this application
or this program we just double click on
this or right click on this you go to
this run as option you see this run as
Java application option so you can hit
this option it will run the application
and it will present all the output here
in the console tab let me just bring
this up so you can see all the variables
have been printed here and this is
coming from these print statements like
I said this is used system.out.println
is used to basically print anything and
I've used that to print all the
variables here first I'm printing the
care variable whose value is a then I'm
using the byte variable which is denoted
by B and whose value is 2 so you can see
the value is 2 here then and printing
the third variable which is C which is a
short type variable which has a value 22
you can see short and this is coming
here the next print statement is int so
you can see int here with the value 45
and this value is coming from here then
we have float we can see the float value
being printed here and you can see the
float value declared here you also see
an F here and this is the standard
naming convention with Java proposes
that whenever you declare float and
double you end them with f or D based on
whether it is float or it is double then
you see the double value which is having
which is having a bigger position than
float so I have printed the double value
using this particular print statement
which is printed here and then we have
the Boolean value which is stored as G
and the value of G is true and the same
value is printed here so whatever I
write here basically is printed here
this is just a placeholder and this is
the actual value so you can see that we
are able to use all the variables here
all the Primitive variables basically
which range from byte character byte
short int float double and Boolean and
that's it for this session in the next
session we will be discussing about the
non primitive data types in Java let's
get started with non-primitive data
types in Java in the previous lecture we
talked about the primitive data types
and now we'll discuss about some of the
data types which are not primitive first
of all let's understand what is the
difference between primitive and
non-primitive so the primitive data
types are the ones which are by default
supported by Java and non-primitives are
the one which are a bit custom in nature
where you as developer have the Liberty
to define the nature of that data type
we'll look at some examples of that as
well but when we talk about which all
are the non-primitive data types we
broadly talk about arrays which talk
about classes we talk about strings as
well and we will cover some of them in
today's lecture and we have the a
detailed lecture upcoming about the
classes as well in fact in the in the
after few lectures we'll we'll cover how
we'll create classes as well but for
today's lecture we are going to focus on
string data type and array data type and
like I said for classes we have a
dedicated lecture upcoming so don't
worry about that and again for this
particular case as well I have already
prepared a demo for this and we'll
basically do some look at some Hands-On
examples to see how do we create these
variables what is what does these
variables mean and the first
non-primitive data type we are going to
talk about is string and before I go on
further I should also mention that it's
very debatable in the Java Community to
call string as a non-primitive data type
and actually technically speaking string
is a special data type it neither fully
lies in the Primitive category nor it
fully lies in the non-primitive
categories I am covering this as a
non-primitive data type because it's a
bit inclined towards the non-primitive
category why do we uh do this is because
Java does provide native support for
string handling in the jdk and that's
the reason some of the developers feel
that string is a primitive data type
which is primitively supported by Java
but at the same time string is so
customizable and it's so special in
nature it's the way it stores the value
the way it provides the operations and
handlings it's so different than
primitive data types that it cannot
fully be put in the same bucket as the
primitive data types so that's why I
said it's it's a special data type a bit
inclined towards the non-primitive
category so what is string basically we
covered about the cad data type in the
previous lecture and in care data type
you you can only store A Single
Character right but if you want to store
a complete name of somebody then it's a
list of character it's basically lot of
characters together then in that case
you would need a data type to store that
continuous sequence of characters and
that's what string does string can store
a continuous sequence of characters
technically string is basically a
character array you can call string as a
character array and don't worry if you
don't understand about the word array I
will explain that in the same lecture so
basically it stores The Continuous
sequence of characters that's how that's
how we Define string and you see this
string this is a basically the keyword
the data type basically in Java so
whenever you want to create a string you
need to write string with S capital you
need to give a name to the string this
can be anything and then you can provide
the value which is which this particular
string is going to contain so you can
see this is a continuous sequence of
characters te EST are the four
characters which this string is going to
contain and after that again I'm
printing this particular value and like
I said don't worry about this we'll
cover this when we'll when we'll write
our first program in Java so this is
just to print the string value I'm just
putting a string Place folder here and
then I'm actually putting the printing
the values of the string variable now
string can be created in multiple ways
in Java this is one way of creating it
there's another way of creating a string
variable which is this one which says
again the string data type some variable
name a keyword called new again don't
worry about what is this new keyword
we'll cover this when we'll talk about
running our first program in Java and
writing the first program from scratch
then we again say string and then we
provide the value so if I compare this
line number four to line number seven
you can see the differences that I am
still storing the same value test but
the difference is that here there is no
new string keyword but here we have this
new string keyword so what is the
difference the difference is this that
in this case in this particular case
string is going to reuse the same object
multiple times but in this case every
time you call this it is going to create
a new object again what is object it's
just you can think of it as for now you
can think of it as a memory block we'll
Again cover objects in details but these
are two different ways in which you can
create string this is generally the most
popular way of doing it because this is
memory efficient because you can reuse
the same variable again and again so I'm
creating the string variable here and
creating another string variable str1
here and printing both of them then I've
created this strange looking thing here
which is basically an array array like I
said is also an a non-primitive data
type in Java and array can store a
continuous sequence of anything that
anything can be a number that anything
can be characters that anything can be
or a floating number as well so basic
idea is that if you want to store a
collection or sequence of multiple
multiple uh values how do you do that
you do that with the help of arrays
array is a data structure a non-primited
data structure in Java which can store
lot of values of similar type we also
call it as homogeneous data structure
which because it can only store same
data type values a homogeneous data type
values so the the biggest way to
identify array is this square bracket
whenever you see the square bracket in
Java it means it's an it's an array
variable so here I am creating an
integer array variable with the name ARR
this is the name of this particular
array it is only going to store integer
values because of specified int and the
moment I provide the square brackets its
mean it means that it is an array so you
can declare an array like this and then
you need to assign a size to the array
size is basically denoting how many
values this data structure is going to
store so I am saying new again it's a
keyword and I'm saying that okay create
a memory block for storing two integers
so this particular array ARR can store
at Max two values two values at
continuous locations the next thing
about array is that it stores the value
in a zero index based location so like I
said it can store two values so the
first location will always be array of 0
and this is how you specify the location
or index of the element which is going
to be stored so at the zeroth location
of this array I'm storing 0 the first
location of the array I'm storing one
and this is just to show an error
scenario but I will just comment this
for now you can just put double slashes
and comment any line so I'm just storing
filling up this array for two values and
the two values this location would be
zero index and first index these are
just continuous memory locations and we
denote those memory locations as 0 and 1
array indexes always start with 0 and
I'm just putting some values here you
can put any values and then I'm printing
the whole array and I'm also printing
the first value of the array and we'll
see how this pans out and we'll also see
how we can change this so now we are
going to run this application so I'll
just go to run as and click on run as
Java application and once I hit that I
get this output here so let's understand
this output the first one is I'm just
printing the string which has the value
test and you can see it has printed here
it is coming from this line then the
next line which is printed is line
number eight where I'm saying another
string str1 and str1 also had the same
value so you can see another string has
the same value and then I have printed
the array here the complete array and
you see this change value here it also
tells us that if you want to print the
array then you cannot just put the
variable name and print it the reason is
because this is a non-primitive data
type and once you do this it is
basically printing the memory footprint
of this array the whole memory location
where this array is stored that's why
you see this strange looking number
which is the memory hash code and if you
want to print any particular value or
any particular element inside this array
then you can do that by providing the
index location of that element so here I
have said that print the 0th location
element of the array the zeroth location
array element of the array was 0 so you
can see the value 0 here let me put some
other value just to just for fun and
show you how this works so just change
the values and now let's see what do we
get for array 0 we can see now I get
value 3 because now that at the zeroth
location the three value is being stored
and that is what is being printed here
we can also print the first value I'll
just go run as Java application you can
see now the array of first index is
being stored which is basically
technically the second element of the
array but because array always works on
a zero index based value uh format
that's why when we say array 1 the
second element is printed when I say
array 0 the first element is printed so
always remember that array is a zero
index based collection or data structure
basically what happens if I do this now
there is no third element in this array
because the array has the size only of
two elements and when I say ARR of 2
which means I'm trying to print the
third element in this array which does
not exist so let's see what happens in
that case I get an exception exception
is basically an error I get an error
saying that index 2 is out of bounds for
length 2. it means that the array length
was actually 2 and index 2 does not
exist remember it's saying index two not
the element two index 2 doesn't exist
because only index 0 and index 1 exist
this makes two elements and the actual
size is also two it does not have
capacity to store third element it does
not have third element location anywhere
that's why it complains that you are
trying to print a non-existing value so
this is where I would like to conclude
my lecture about the non primitive data
types so we covered about string we
covered arrays and like I said we'll
cover classes in the upcoming lecture as
well in the next session we are going to
talk about tokens in Java let's get
started with tokens in Java when we talk
about tokens in Java these tokens are
basically some reserved expressions or
words or symbols which have a predefined
meaning in Java and you cannot override
this meaning because this meaning is
already defined by Java and you can use
those expressions those symbols and
those words in in only the way Java
wants you to there is no way you can
change the meaning of those terms or
those symbols so we will be covering
those tokens in today's lecture these
tokens are broadly divided into five
different categories these categories
are keywords identifiers constants
special symbols and operators so let's
talk about each of them one by one so
when we talk about keywords these are
the words which are reserved by Java and
they have a predefined meaning you might
have already seen some of these reserved
keywords for example we have used int
when we were working on the primitive
data type lecture we have seen this as
well though we haven't actually found
out the meaning of this but we will find
out the meaning of this in the coming
lectures so don't worry about that we
have seen Boolean as a as a data type
again we have seen by it so these
Boolean byte end class scared catch
super switch synchronized all the all
the keywords which you see here these
keywords have a predefined meaning in
Java and you use these keywords so that
you want to take an action an expected
action by Java for example if you call
something as int then you want Java to
treat it as int int will only have a
single meaning in Java and there is no
other meaning of int in a Java program
so that's the intent with the keywords
these are reserved Words which have a
predefined meaning and we will cover
these keywords at length during this
whole course the next token is
identifier and identifier is is nothing
but just a variable name technically and
we have already covered this this kind
of identifier when we were showing the
demonstrations for primitive data types
and non-premitive data types Etc it's
basically anything which you declare as
a variable is an identifier and when you
declare the variable name again Java
puts some sort of restrictions as to
what you can or cannot do when you work
with Java and you declare the variable
names for example these variable names
cannot start with numbers so you cannot
have a variable name which starts with
any number you cannot have a variable
name which contains spaces in between
them you either have to fill those uh if
there's a if there's a variable name
which you think has two parts for
example student name then you need to
write it as student underscore name so
that you can create the variable name
with the same impact and still does not
contain space so spaces will not be
allowed when you create the variable
names similarly you cannot have plus
hyphen and Ampersand in the variable
names as well these are the restrictions
which Java puts on the identifier tokens
when whenever you create identifiers the
next one is constants and we will cover
these constants in detail in the coming
lectures as well but to give you an idea
of what caused constants are so
constants are basically exactly what
they sound like they are the identifiers
which you have declared in your program
whose value cannot be changed once
defined so if you write something as
final int I equal to 5 then this value
is fixed you cannot change the value of
I again in the program Java will not
allow you to change the value of I again
because I has now become a constant
because you have put a final keyword in
front of it and again final is a keyword
you see final is a keyword basically so
you so these constants are treated
specially by Java that Java will make
sure that their values will never change
during the course of the execution of
the program this can come really handy
when you have situations where you do
not want the certain variables values to
be to be modified for example if you
have an application where you are
counting the number of applicants and if
you have declared the number of
applicants as final then every time you
call the application you can do a plus
one to the previous value the value will
not be re-initiated so it is very useful
concept and and it can be very handy in
programs where you don't want to change
the values the next is special symbols
these special symbols are the symbols
which again have a predefined meaning in
Java we have already seen this square
bracket symbol in our previous lecture
when we were creating arrays so whenever
you use these square brackets then Java
would understand that you are trying to
either access or create an array or you
are trying to access or create a list
Etc so this is predefined you cannot use
this anywhere else or with any other
meaning similarly when we talk about
these braces these standard brackets or
standard braces these again have a
predefined meaning in Java generally
whenever you will write functions and
methods in Java you will use these
bracket it's to define the parameters of
the function now you cannot use these
brackets in any other meaning in Java
Java will not allow you to use this
anywhere else apart from using it in
method parameters similarly the next one
is the curly braces and the curly braces
are used to define a code Block in Java
you might have already noticed that when
we were looking at the previous demos
you could see some curly brushes then
some code and then the then the curly
brushes would end for example if I show
you here just it's just a sample example
and let me open the example which we
covered in the last lecture so you can
see this curly brush here and this curly
brush ends here right so this defines a
code Block in Java any code block which
you want Java to understand will always
be starting with a curly braces and
ending with a curly brace remember I
talked about the standard braces you can
see these are the standard braces
opening and ending and this is where we
are defining this particular methods
arguments now what is Method what is
argument don't worry about that we will
cover in detail but just an introductory
concept whenever you are trying to
define a method and you want to pass any
argument to the method we use these
brackets to do that okay uh similarly
this is semicolon is used to close any
Java statement so you will see this
semicolon here every Java statement has
to have a semicolon as ending otherwise
Java will complain that it is a
syntactical error so it is part of the
syntax you need to put the semicolon and
semicolon has only one meaning in Java
which is that your statement is actually
ending uh then we have star and star is
used for multiplication and then we have
equality which is used for assigning any
values and again assigning any values is
everywhere you are seeing this equality
sign everywhere so these are all tokens
basically the last type of token we have
is operators and we will cover these
operators in the upcoming lectures in
detail with the examples but these
operators are basically some special
symbols like for arithmetic it would be
plus minus multiplication divide for
comparison it will be greater than less
than for logical it would be Ampersand
and and pipe operators bitwise again
will have some bitwise operation
operators so the so these are basically
different categories of operators and
under each category of operators there
are certain symbols like for arithmetic
we have plus minus we have com for
comparison we have greater than less
than etcetera so these again symbols are
also reserved by Java Under The
Operators tokens category you cannot use
these in any other meaning or in any
other way and like I said we will look
at a detailed example of this as well in
the coming lectures so this was a quick
overview of what are different types of
tokens in Java so we have keywords we
have identifiers constants special
symbols and operators so this is it this
is all what I wanted to cover in today's
lecture and in the next session we will
be looking at data type conversions
let's get started with data type
conversions so when we talk about data
type conversion the whole idea is to
basically answer the question that
whether I can convert a ins data type
variable into a long data type variable
or a long data type variable to a float
data type variable and also vice versa
can I go back can I convert a float
variable into a long variable or an INT
variable and vice versa so this lecture
is about answering all of those
questions and we will basically look at
some examples to understand how the
conversion works but let me just explain
the basic principle the basic principle
is that smaller box can fit into larger
box but if we have to fit a larger box
into a smaller box you need to do
something else so what do you mean by
smaller box and larger box here the
smaller box box is a variable or a data
type which has a smaller range if you
remember we talked about the range of
short byte end Etc and we could see that
as we go from short to byte to int to
long to float to double the ranges were
increasing right so we will follow the
same kind of analogy that if we have to
store our smaller range variable into a
larger range variable Java will
automatically do that but if I have to
store a larger range variable into a
smaller range variable then I have to
sacrifice some quality of the value and
we will look at the examples of that as
well so let's first look at look at the
example where we can store a smaller
range variable into a larger range
variable we call this as implicit data
type conversion so here you can see I
have declared an INT variable with the
value 100 and I'm printing the variable
then I have declared a long variable and
what I am doing that I am assigning the
value of int a to the long variable B so
I'm not assigning a new value to this
long variable but rather I'm just
passing on the existing integer value
into a variable of type long similarly
after that I am taking the value of this
variable of long type and storing this
value into a float type so you can see
int is basically smaller than long and
long has a smaller range than float so
I'm just storing a smaller range
variable into a larger range and then a
larger range variable into the largest
range and then I am printing all the
variables values to see if this actually
is working can long automatically store
the value of a and can float
automatically store the value of B here
I'm just printing the variables and
again using the concept of the previous
lecture this is just to to print the
values and I will cover this in detail
in the next lectures of how this works
but here you can understand that we can
use system dot out dot println to
basically print the values and here I'm
just printing a string and then the
value then again the string and the
value and here also the string and the
value so this is what is happening in
this program and again don't worry about
these details I will cover about what
these concepts are in the upcoming
lectures so let's run this and see if
the data type conversion actually works
so I will just right click and do run as
and go to Java application and if I
click on this I get this output so the
first output is pretty straightforward
I'm just printing the int variable as is
so this works then I am storing the int
into a log and printing the long
representation of a which is B basically
and this also works without any errors
or any warnings by Java similarly when I
talk about storing the long variable
into a float variable will see this also
works but here you see an additional
decimal Precision here because as we
remember from the previous sessions
float is used to store values which have
decibels or which have precisions so it
will automatically convert your absolute
number into a number which has decimals
whenever you try to cast this into float
casting is also a word which is used
some people call it as implicit data
type conversion some people call it as
implicit data type casting so if you
hear the word data type casting or
implicit data type casting you can think
that it is exactly the same concept as
data type conversion so this is about
implicit data type conversion now let's
look at an example of explicit data type
conversion how does that work so using
the same analogy of the boxes now I will
try to store a larger ranging value
variable into a smaller range variable
and see how that looks like so I will
start with the largest which is which is
double variable so I have created a
double variable and as we know that
double is a is a variable which is used
to store decimal values so I'm storing
this value here and then I'm just
printing the double representation as is
without any changes then I'm trying to
store this variables value into a float
variable so I'm trying to go to a
smaller box now I'm trying to grow from
double to float and if you remember I
told you that if you have to do that it
will not work out of the box but you
have to do a bit uh something special as
well and this is the special part this
is called type casting type casting is
basically a way to tell Java to
explicitly cast this variable's value
into this data types variables value and
you always need to do this Whenever
there is no implicit casting happening
if you are trying to store a larger
value variable into a smaller value
variable you have to do this otherwise
Java will complain you will get a
compilation error so that's what I'm
doing I'm telling Java to store the
value of a as a float and store the
value in F and this is where I'm telling
to store the value as float so you just
put brackets and you define float and
then I'm printing the float
representation similarly in the next one
I am trying to store the value of this
double variable into a long so you can
see now I'm trying to go even from our
Precision data type to a non-precision
data type because long does not
understand decimal values so I'm trying
to store a variable which has decimal
values into a variable data type which
does not understand decimal values and
we will see how the output looks like
but here also you need to do the
explicit casting explicitly you need to
tell which data type this a needs to be
converted into that's what I do here and
then I print the long variable here and
then next I will again go down further
and I will try to store a larger long
variable type into a smaller int
variable type so again I'm trying to
store the value of B into a smaller data
type which is integer and I'm naming the
variable as C here again I have to do
this explicit casting I'm telling that
telling Java to explicitly cast the
value of B which is a long data type
variable into an integer C which is an
INT data type variable and then I'm just
printing the value so this is what is
happening in this program that from
double to float to long to end now let's
run this program and see what happens so
I will right click and go to run as and
choose the Java application option and
this is the output I get first of all
for the double representation the value
gets printed 0 is ignored then in the
float it works fine as well without any
Precision loss because float can also
print values up to one to two decimal
points without any problems even beyond
that actually so it works fine then when
we talk talk about the long
representation we are trying to convert
a double variable into a long variable
and we see that the Precision the
decimal values are lost this is expected
because log does not understand decimal
values that's why anything after the
decibel or in fact the whole decimal
portion is gone when you're trying to
store double or float into some Absolute
Data type variables like tint or long
and then in in representation since you
already have this long this long can
easily be casted to int by just
providing this explicit casting and the
end representation also prints 50. so we
started from this value and we ended up
with these values when we try to store
them as long or int so this is all I
wanted to cover in in today's lecture so
we covered basically about the data type
conversion or data type casting Concepts
how does implicit data type casting
works and how does explicit data type
casting works and as we know the concept
the basic concept is that the the value
you can easily be casted from a smaller
range to a larger range without any
changes or without any extra code but
when you have to go from a larger value
to a smaller value you have to provide
these casting instructions to Java to
successfully cast those variables in the
next session we will be looking at how
we can write the first hello world
program in Java and there we will
actually cover all the all these things
which which I have been saying that we
will cover so we will cover all these
ways of how we can write the first hello
world program in Java let's get started
with how to write your first program in
Java so I have been talking about this
lecture and the details of this lecture
in the previous lectures as well and
today we are going to focus exactly on
how do we actually write a Java program
so as we have already covered how you
can install eclipse and how you can
create a sample Java project in Eclipse
if you haven't seen that please go back
to my previous videos where you can
actually see that and once you have
created your Java project so your Java
project might look like something like
this you will have an SRC folder here so
and under the SRC folder you see some
some namespaces sort of things created
here right we call these as packages and
in Java you can think of package as
something which can group multiple
related artifacts together this is
simply a grouping mechanism I can say
it's a way to put all the related
artifacts to a particular business
problem into a certain place for example
if you are working in an e-commerce
application so you have you might have
created multiple Java files for let's
say for checkout and then some more Java
files for the uh filters flow I would
say then some other Java files for
Designing the advertisements so you have
multiple Java files and these Java files
now below belong to these three
different domains so you want to group
them together for easy accessibility for
referencing each other files with the
within the code so if you want to
achieve that kind of flexibility you
would group the checkout code files into
a single package you can name it as
checkout package then you can similarly
do the same thing for the advertisement
package and for the filters package so
similarly I have created some packages
here which you can see you see a package
here which says IO GitHub vikesh Pandey
hello world and how do you create a
package you just right click on this so
you go to the SRC and you right click to
go to new and here you will see this
option which says package so you can
just click on this and write anything
which you want as the package name let's
call it as test package it says invalids
because the package is a keyword so it
is not allowing me to put package here
but let's call it test package one and
you can just click finish and you will
see a test package popping up here then
you can right click on this again go to
new and then you can create a Java class
now what is a Java class a class is
basically a blueprint for an object it's
basically the specifications of an
object like I covered in the very first
lecture everything in Java is an object
or most of the things in Java are object
I would say so object is basically an
instance of the class so let's say you
create a class for if I take the same
example of e-commerce you create a class
for writing the business logic of
checkout and then you create instance of
this particular class to work for a
particular customer order so class is
basically a blueprint it's the
specification it's the skeleton of the
object so once you click on this you can
create a class now eclipse is a pretty
smart IDE it will provide you with bunch
of options on how you actually can
create a class what and it will also
provide use with some sensible defaults
for example it will automatically select
a source folder in your project which
you have created it will automatically
select a package in fact the currently
selected package and if you want to
change the package just hit browse and
choose any other package which you want
to choose so your your class file will
be created in that package then you can
provide a name to the class so let's
call it as test hello world and you can
see I have followed a sort of a naming
convention here the first character I've
kept it as capital and then any other
new word which is coming in my class
file name is also capitalized so Java
would expect you or and it would
encourage you to follow this naming
convention that whenever you are
creating a class always start with a
capital letter then small letters and
every new word you are writing can start
with a capital letter again Java will
not throw an error if you don't do this
h capital or W Capital but it's a good
practice the next thing is the modifier
we are going to cover the body fires in
details in the in the upcoming lectures
but for now you can understand that
anything which is marked as public is
accessible to every other Java class in
this whole project that's the basic
meaning of making a class as Public
public has the names suggests itself it
means it's visible to everyone so you
can select a super class and again we'll
talk about this super class later but
this is the Java Lang object is the
super class of all the classes which are
created in Java again interface is again
an advanced concept and there are some
other interesting uh defaults it
provides for the for example if you want
to create a main method now what is the
main method we'll just cover it in a
while so I will not do that I will leave
everything as default and I will click
on finish so I have this new file coming
up here and you can see it has
automatically picked up the package
which I selected and it has also written
public class test hello world with a
starting and ending curly braces in the
previous lecture we covered about these
curly braces that all the code block
have to be in the curly braces whenever
you write a Java class the very first
statement Java would expect to have in
the class is package name so make sure
that you have package as a keyword and
then the actual package name as the
package name for that particular class
you can see the package follows a DOT
convention and it always ends with a
semicolon like all the Java statements
and with semicolon so that would be the
first thing which you will write in your
class second thing is the access
modifier of the class like I said you
want this class to be accessible to
every other file in this project then
you can mark this class as public the
next thing is the class keyword you need
to write this particular keyword as is
otherwise your class will not be
detected so you write this as class then
you write test hello world or whatever
name you want to write but make sure
that whatever public class name you
provide here that name should match with
the file name these two things should
match the file name and the class name
if they don't match you would experience
weird behaviors as the class will not be
compiled the class might not be able to
run Etc so always make sure that
whatever file name you provide you
always have a class with that name in
your file so my class structure is is
ready but there's nothing here in this
class in fact you cannot you cannot even
execute this class because for executing
the class for executing any class in
Java any class at all in Java you would
need a main method in Java main method
is the entry point method of the Java
whenever you are trying to run any
application be it a very small or very
large Java application you would always
and always need a main method in the in
the class in the project somewhere and
you need to tell the Java runtime time
to execute that class and then the class
will have a main method and the your
program will start executing so always
have a main method otherwise your
program will not execute and how do you
write the main method so you first write
public then you write static
then you write void
and then you write Main and then you
provide a parameter to this method as
this now let's understand what did I
actually write here first keyword is
public because this method has to be
public because like I said Java runtime
needs to be able to access this method
so the similar concept which applied on
the class is applied on this method as
well that the entry point method has to
be public otherwise Java will not be
able to find this method so you need to
make this method exactly as public the
next keyword is static you again need to
write this keyword as is and the reason
we write static here is because we we
want to run this particular class
without creating an object of the class
static is again a keyword which we will
cover in the upcoming lectures but for
now you can understand that whenever you
want to access something within the
class without creating an object then
you need to create it as static then
next is void void is basically the
return type of this method the method
name is Main and it has to be main it
cannot be main one or main two otherwise
if you do that Java will not be able to
run your program because it will expect
you to write this particular method
exactly as what I have written here no
changes at all should be there if you
make any changes Java program will not
run because it will not be able to find
the entry point method which is the main
method so public static void main
remember that you need to have this in
your program so white is the return type
which means that this particular program
will not return anything back to the
runtime because a method can have this
capability to either return something or
not return something for example a
method which can add two numbers will
return the result of addition right so
we return the result return is the word
here in this case this method is not
expected to return anything because
there is nobody consuming it right Java
runtime will not do anything with the
with the return value of this particular
method that's why Java will force you to
write void here and Main is the exact
method name which you need to use Java
will expect you to supply a string array
argument if we covered arrays in bit
detail in the in the in the previous
lectures and we will cover arrays in
actually in the next lecture in very
detail but you can as we discussed that
array is basically a sequence of
characters or words or integers or
anything right so in this case this is
basically the mandatory parameter which
you need to write as is this parameter
name can be anything obviously it can be
ARG args or whatever you want to write
it as but the basic fundamental is that
Java will basically supply all the
command line arguments using this
particular string array that's why you
need to provide this then let's write
something in the program because this is
a Hello World program so I will just
write system Dot out dot print Ln and
I'll type A String here which says hello
world and a semicolon so again I have
been saying that I will explain this and
now I will explain this why do we need
this and what does this mean so as I
have told earlier that whenever you want
to print something on the console in a
Java program you need to write
system.out.print Ln now system here if
you just go if you just hover over it
Eclipse will show what it is so system
is basically a class which contains
several useful class fields and methods
it cannot be instantiated means you
cannot create an object of it and it
provides many facilities like standard
input standard output and error output
exactly what we want to focus here
because we want to use system class to
print something on the standard output
the standard output in this case is the
console so if you want to input
something or you want to output
something or you want to Output an error
then you need to use system class and
all of these standard input standard
output and error are streams and that's
what comes to the next word what is this
out out is a stream to print standard
output similarly we have
system.err which is for printing the
error output streams similarly we have
system.in for taking its standard input
streams so system.in system.out
system.err these all are these in out
and err are streams and then print Ln is
the actual method let's hover over that
let's first see out here so you can see
this is a stream object which is used to
print anything which is ready to accept
output data basically and then we go to
the println method and it says prints a
string and then terminate the line so
like I mentioned earlier as well this
whole syntax is used to print and
actually this is the code method this is
the real method which prints something
on the console so system class uses the
output stream to print something on the
console using the help of print Ln
method there is also a print method so
there are two methods one is printer one
is print Ln the difference is that in
case of print method the print method
will not provide you or terminate on a
next line but in system.out.print Ln the
Ln means line here it will print
something and it will bring the cursor
to the next line if you do not use this
and if you again use another print
statement then both of the statements
will be printed on the same line I will
show that as well but and then we
provide any random string here which we
want to print so you right click on this
particular program you go to run as and
you run as Java application and you want
to save this so you can say always save
resources before launching and you see
the output here so this is how you can
run your first Java program now let's
also see the difference between
system.out.print Ln and system.out.print
so I will just copy this here and I'll
say hello world 1 let's say and this
time I will not use system.out.print Ln
but I will use system.out.print
just put a space here so that it's
visible so if I use print how does that
look like I go to run and I go to run as
Java application so now you see both of
the outputs are printed on the same line
there is no this output hasn't gone to
the next line and now if I run the same
program with system.out.print Ln methods
now both of these outputs will be
divided on two lines the first output
then a line break the hello world 1 goes
to the next line in the previous run the
hello world one was printing right next
to it on the same line so that is the
difference so this is how you can build
your very first program the hello world
program in Java in the next session we
will be discussing about arrays in Java
let's get started with arrays in Java we
discussed about arrays in a bit detail
when we talked about the non primitive
data types but this is a concept and a
topic which needs to be understood well
so that's why we'll go we'll do a deep
live on arrays in this particular
lecture so as I described earlier that
array is basically a container which can
store values or a sequence of values or
sequence of numbers or sequence of
characters into itself we can think of
it as a box which can store all the
values in a continuous fashion as you
can see here this is just a pictorial
representation and this is coming from
the official Java docs and you can see
that we if we create an array of size 10
then we have these 10 blocks created
here you can see 1 to 10 so the whole
length of boxes the number of boxes here
are 10 but the way arrays are designed
is that the index index is basically
used to access the element in this
particular box the index of the boxes
start from zero so it goes from 0 to 9
so remember the array length is 10 it
array in the array can contain 10
elements points but the index of the
array starts with 0 and will always end
at length minus 1 which is 10 minus 1 in
this case which comes as 9 so it will
always be length minus 1 it will always
the index will always start from 0 and
go till length minus 1 length can be
anything in this case the length is 10
so the index ends at 9 if the length was
20 the last index will be 19 but in
total you have these 10 memory locations
we also call them as continuous memory
locations because they are continuously
placed and array basically blocks 10
memory locations and creates a container
over it so this is how an array
basically looks like inside the memory
and whenever you want to access the
elements of the array you will say array
of 0 or array of 1 or array of 2 you
basically need to specify the index to
access the element at index for example
if you want to access the element which
is sitting in this box you need to say
array of index 8 and we'll see how we
can do that but this is the basic
understanding and idea of the concept of
arrays so let's try to understand this
with the help of an example I will
switch back to Eclipse IDE and I've
created a very simple program here to
demonstrate the functionality of arrays
here so we already covered in the
previous lecture of what is package and
what is public and what is class how do
we give the class name and what is the
meaning of this particular method so I'm
not going to cover that again we'll
start directly from here so here the
first thing which I am doing is I'm
declaring an array of integer this is a
variable name the identifier basically
it can be anything and this is the data
type it's an integer array and as we as
we covered this as well that whenever
you put square bracket in front of a
data type it becomes an array data type
so this is an integer array
representation now we just declared an
array but we still haven't allocated a
size to it so you can do that with this
particular syntax so you can put the
variable name of the array and say new
int and put the right size here this
size can be anything and once you do
this now array will actually allocate
those memory boxes which we covered here
but the moment you do new into 10 this
box these boxes continuous boxes will be
placed in the memory and the memory is
allocated to this array we call this
memory allocation this is how you
allocate memory to the array so we
allocated memory to this array for
storing 10 integers the next thing is
now we can start storing elements in
those boxes so like I said that the
array index always starts with 0 so if
you have to store the first element you
actually have to store it at index 0
location so you give the array name you
provide these square brackets and you
put the index value within the square
brackets that is how you base basically
point to a particular element inside the
array so we say an array of 0 and we put
the value 100 then we initialize the
second element which will be index 1
then will be the third element which
will be index two fourth element index 3
Fifth Element index four Sixth Element
index 5 and so on until we store till
the last element so this is the tenth
element which is accessible as index 9
and the value is a thousand basically so
from 100 to thousand we stored 10 values
in this array and we stored them by
accessing the index and this is actually
the only way you can store values in the
array by pointing to the indexes so we
go from 0 to 9 and we stored all the
values 0 being the first element and
array of 9 being the last and the tenth
element remember the length minus one
concept okay so now we will try to print
all the elements one by one that's
pretty much what we are doing now so as
we covered in the the previous lecture
that we use
system.out.print Ln to print anything
and we understood the whole meaning of
this so I'm not going to repeat that now
we want to print the first element the
first element is sitting at index 0 and
we can access that element with this
syntax by providing the variable name
and the actual index value so I'm just
writing a random string here which says
a limited index 0 and then I'm putting
this plus here and putting the variable
name this plus is basically used to
concatenate the output of a static
string with a random variable or
basically you can print anything with
using plus plus is used for
concatenation so I am just trying to
print this whole value but here this is
a string value which is a static string
and then I have a value coming from the
array so whenever you have to print some
value from a particular data type or
variable or collection then you can use
this plus syntax to to concatenate a
string static string with your actual
value so that's what I've done here by
saying plus and array 0 and similarly
for index 1 I'm printing the the first
index then for 2 3 so far and so on so
forth till the index 9. so basically I'm
just printing the all the values of the
array starting from index 0 to index 9.
so that's all which which is written in
this program now let's try to run this
program so I will right click go to run
as and go to Java application and hit on
this and now if I just expand this
console you can see all the
system.out.printellent statements have
been executed and they printed this so
this is the static screen string part in
fact including the colon this is the
static string part element and index 0
printing exactly as is and then
dynamically the zeroth index element of
an array is printed here similarly we
have printed the index 1 location
element index 2 location element index 3
location element and so on so forth till
the index 9 location element so in total
these are the 10 elements but the index
always works from 0 to length minus 1 in
this case it will be going from 0 to 9.
so this is basically all which I wanted
to cover in this lecture the whole idea
was to give you more understanding of
arrays and remember this is just an
integer array you can similarly create a
character array you can also create a
string array for for you as well so it
it's completely uh it's completely
related to the data type you are using
if you create a care array then you can
only store characters into it if you
create a string array then you can only
store strings into it and now you can
probably relate back to this particular
thing which I explained in the previous
lecture that we create the string array
for the reason that when you run this
particular program and if you want to
provide any command line values command
line arguments to the program those
arguments will automatically be stored
in this args and then you can access
this as args of 0 args of one Etc in
your program that's the whole concept so
these are this is the basically the Deep
dive one array which I wanted to cover
and in the next session we are going to
cover about operators in Java let's get
started with operators in Java when we
talk about operators in Java there are
multiple types of operators like
assignment operators arithmetic
operators unary operators then we have
conditional operators and logical
operators and we also have bitwise
operators and we will cover all of these
operators one by one we will understand
what what these operators are and how
they work and we will also look at a
demonstration of it so let's get started
the first operators we are going to
discuss is about arithmetic operators
and assign assignment operators and we
will also see if we can cover Visionary
operators so when we talk about
assignment operators I have again opened
the official Java docs here if we
understand assignment operators we have
been using this operators all the while
in all of the demos so far and the basic
idea is very simple whenever you assign
a value to a variable you use the
assignment operator which is nothing but
the equal sign we have already covered
this in multiple demos so I will not
cover this as part of the demo but what
I'm going to cover in detail is about
these arithmetic operators so arithmetic
operators are basically used to perform
any kind of arithmetic operation on a
Java program it can be an additional
operation it can be a subtraction
operation it can be a multiplication
operation or division operation or in
operation by which you can find the
remainder of the division so we will
look at each of these with an example
and as you can see the symbols are
expectedly what you generally use in
mathematics so you see the the plus sign
here which is for addition you see the
minus sign which is for subtraction you
see the star sign which is for
multiplication you see the slash sign
which is for division and you see the
percentage sign which is for finding the
remainder of a division so let's see an
example of each of these and how we can
use them in a Java program
so for the arithmetic operations I have
prepared a demonstration of it in the
Eclipse IDE again I'm using the same
Java project which I have shown you we
created in our previous lectures so I
will for all the demonstrations I will
just continue on the same project so
again the way to create a class Remains
the Same exactly the same as how I
covered in the previous lecture in the
hello world program where we created a
class so here also I created a class I
named the class as arithmetic demo and I
have a public static void main method
inside this particular class and I have
basically tried to demonstrate each of
the operation so let's start with the
additional operation first so I create
an integer variable here named as result
and then I try to use the addition
operator to make this variable store the
result of this Edition so it's a simple
one plus two you can also create two
different variables for one and two
let's say X equal to 1 and y equal to 2
and you can also do int result equal to
X Plus y it will have the same effect
but just for Simplicity I have put the
literal numbers here so result is
storing the the expression value of 1
plus 2 and then I am printing this value
here you can see I am printing the
result variable here with using system
dot out dot println then I'm storing
this result into a variable into a new
variable original result with using the
assignment operator and then I'm trying
to subtract something from it so now I'm
saying result equal to result minus 1 it
means whatever the current value of
result is subtract minus 1 from that
value so the value was 3 here and here 3
minus 1 becomes 2 so the new value of
result becomes 2 the original result
still holds 3 because it is storing the
old value the new value of result has
now become 2 so I'm printing the
original result and then what I'm doing
that I'm again assigning the new result
which is 2 to the original result so now
original result and result both are at 2
then I move ahead and I try to
demonstrate the multiplication operation
so I take the same variable result and I
say multiply it by 2. so whatever the
value of result was which at this place
should be 2 multiply that value by 2 so
2 into 2 the new value of result should
become 4 after this multiplication
operation and again I'm assigning the
value of original result to this
particular variable and then I'm
showcasing the fourth mathematical
arithmetic operation which is division
so you can see result by 2 here so
basically whatever the current value of
result is I am dividing that value by 2
so 4 divided by 2 should become 2 so
again the new value of the result
variable should become 2 then I'm
printing the value and again storing the
value back into the original result then
the next operation is again an addition
operation where I whatever the value of
result is at this particular point which
is 2 add 8 to that particular value so
the new result value becomes 10 and then
I'm printing that particular value again
assigning the original result to the
result and then to showcase the
remainder operation I am doing result we
call this particular operator as mod or
modulus so result modulus 7 so the
current value here is in this case would
be 10 so I'm saying 10 mod 7 so 10 mod 7
would become 3 because if we divide 10
by 7 the remainder should be 3 and this
modulus operator is used to calculate
the remainder of a division operation so
that 3 will be stored in this result
variable and then we print that
particular variable so that is what I'm
doing if I take you back up there I will
just minimize this window and this
window as well so if I take you by back
to the starting I am doing an addition
first here at line seven then I am doing
a subtraction at line 12 then I'm doing
a multiplication at line 17 and a
division at line 22 and then again an
addition at line 27 and then our modulus
at line 32 and I'm printing the
respective values so let us run this
program and see what results do we get
so I right click I go to run as I go to
Java application there is also a
shortcut for it if you want to use the
shortcut you can use that so I click on
this and the output is is displayed here
so you can see let me bring this output
back to its original position yeah I
just dragged it here to the top to the
bottom so if you start from the top and
see what all results did we get printed
so line 9 says 1 plus 2 equal to the
value of result so 1 plus 2 equal to at
this particular point the result will
value was 3 because 1 plus 2 equal to 3
moving on the next variable here is
minus so the current value was 3 we said
3 minus 1 which becomes 2 and we store
the value of result or 3 into this
result variable and we print that value
at line 14. so original result plus
original result is 3 then a string here
minus 1 equal to so this is just a
string and then the actual current
result value which is 2 so far so good
we move ahead and then at line 19 we are
multiplying the current value of result
by 2 and again displaying the original
result and the current value so 2 is the
original result here because here 3
minus 1 had become 2 so original result
value was to multiply that by 2 becomes
4 then moving on to the line 24 2 by 4
by 2 should become 2 so 4 by 2 equals 2
the current value of result then again
and moving on to the next variable at
line 29 now the result value should
become 10 because 2 plus 8 is 10 and
again we are printing the original
result and then the current result value
so the original result was 2 then we
added 8 to it and the new result value
had become 10 which is coming from this
particular variable moving on to line 34
we are again printing the original
result which was 10 here and then we are
saying this particular string which is
modulus 7 and the current value of
result is coming from this expression
which is 10 modulus 7 and like I said
modulus or mod operation is basically
used to calculate the remainder of a
division operation which so 10 divided
by 7 remainder is 3 so that becomes 3
and that's why you see the value 3. so
this is a demonstration to show you how
we can use the addition multiplication
subtraction Division and modulus
operators which are all the error
automatic operators so in the next
session we will be discussing about the
other operator types which are generally
operators and we will also discuss some
other interesting operators which are
popularly used in Java let's get started
with unary operators so when we talk
about unary operators technically they
are also arithmetic operators but they
provide us a shorthand or they have a
more advanced meaning so if you see on
the screen these are the unary operators
we call them as generic plus unary minus
increment Operator decrement Operator
and logical complement operator so when
we talk about the engineering plus
operator basically it is used to
indicate a positive value so whatever
value you are having it will just make
that number as positive number you might
be wondering that this plus has an
addition meaning as well right which we
saw in the previous example yes that's
correct but when we use that addition
symbol we use that between two variables
but when we talk about unary operators
they are used with a single variable
that is why the name generally because
they are used with a single variable
they require only one operand so
generally plus basically makes any
number positive usually minus negates an
expression and makes that number
negative increment operator increments
the value by plus 1 decrement operator
decreases the value by -1 and logical
complement operator inverts the value of
the expression from True to false or
false to True let's understand this with
the help of an example so I have created
a class here called unary demo and I
have a static void main method here and
I have created a variable called result
and the first example is about using
unity plus so I'm creating a variable
called as result assigning the value as
1 and just putting 1 plus in front of it
which makes this as positive value
though we can argue that this also has
the same effect as this and yes that is
true but in case if this value was
written as something like -1 instead of
plus then we could basically make that
number positive by just putting Plus in
front of it so that's basically the
power of unity operators and that's how
you generally use unary operators so
I'll just put it back to plus one the
next example is about decrement
operators so the current value of result
was 1 because we did this now we are
saying result minus minus which means
whatever the value of result is just
decrement it by 1. so the current value
was 1 so now the new value of result
after this evaluation becomes 0 so at
line 14 we print the current value of
result which is 0. moving on at line 16
we are using the increment plus plus
operator here which means whatever the
current value of result is just
increment it by 1 so the current value
of result was 0 till this line so it
becomes 1 because this means increment
by 1. so line 18 will basically print
that value 1 and then at line 20 I'm
using the unary minus operator which
means whatever the value of result is
just negate it just put a negative in
front of it just make that number
negative so if I just say minus result
the current value of result was 1 so it
became minus 1 and then to showcase the
negation operation I created a Boolean
variable named it as success assign the
value of this variable as false and
printed the value of success variable as
is first and then printed the value of
success with a negation in front of it
with an exclamation mark which will
basically flip the value or invert the
value of a Boolean variable so if this
was false line 28 should print true if
this was true line 28 should print false
in this case this is false so the line
28 should print true so let's right
click on this and run this program and
see if we get the expected output and
yes we see the output here so let's try
to interpret the output now the line 10
should print 1 yes then line 14 should
print 0 we see 0 here line 18 should
print 1 because we use the increment
plus plus so 0 plus 1 became 1 then we
use the unary minus operator so the
value should become -1 yes we see minus
1 here and then for Boolean variable we
should see first of all because the
value is printed as is and then we are
printing a negated value so we should
flip the value from false to true and
yes it is printing the value as true so
this was about unary operators now when
we talk about this increment and
decrement operators what if I put this
particular value in front of result what
effect is that going to happen let's
analyze that part as well so for that I
have prepared a separate demo again I've
created a class called pre-post demo and
it has a public static void main method
I'm declaring an integer variable I with
the value as 3 so the I becomes 3 here
and then I'm saying I plus plus as we
have already seen in the unary demo
example this should increment the value
of 3 to 4 so it will print 4 expected
right then at line number nine I am
putting this plus plus in front of I now
what will happen now it is going to
increment the value of I and then
basically assigning the value of I so
the whole difference between I plus plus
and plus plus I is that in this case the
value of I is assigned first and
increment later in this case the value
of I is incremented first and assigned
later so here the value from 4 becomes 5
so at line 11 if you see if we print I
it will print 5 because we have we are
saying that first increment the value
and then update the value of I so
increment happens on I equal to 4 and I
becomes 5. at line number 13 it becomes
more interesting because here inside the
system.out.print Ln statement itself I
am saying plus plus I now what will
happen like I explained first the value
will be incremented and then the value
will be assigned so before printing the
value is getting incremented so the
value from 5 becomes 6 here at line 13
but if I try to do this now I am saying
first assign the value of I and then
increment it so so I at this line is
still 6 because I has already been
assigned 6 and as the post increment
says if we put this plus plus after the
variable it means that you are first
assigning the value and then
incrementing the value so anything which
happens after line 15 the value of I
will become 7 but at line 15 the value
of I is still 6 because we are using a
post increment operator so the value is
still assigned to I as is and then
incremented and when we do
system.out.println the assigned value is
printed not the incremented value so
like I said after line 15 the value of I
will become incremented by 1 and it will
become 7 so hope you understood this
example or and the difference between
the pre-increment and post increment
remember the thumb rule that if we put
plus plus before a variable like at line
number nine the value will be
incremented first and then assigned so
at line 13 the updated value will be
printed because the first we are doing
the increment and then we are printing
the value for assigning the value
similarly at line 15 we are first
printing the value and then incrementing
the value so when the value is printed
at line 15 the old value 5 will be
printed but after line 15 the new value
of I will be accessible to the program
so let's right click on this and run
this program and now if we see the
values we assigned I to 3 we did a post
increment here so I becomes 4 we print
the value of I so here the value of I is
4 you see 4 here then at line line nine
we are saying plus plus I so 4 plus 1
becomes 5 though this is a pre-increment
but since we are not printing this plus
plus I as is it does not have any any
change so the value of 4 becomes 5 at
line 11 we print 5 then at line 30 team
we are saying plus plus I which means
increment the value of I first and then
assign it so the value of 5 becomes 6
and then I gets updated and printed
similarly at line 15 first the value of
I is assigned and printed and then
incremented so at line 15 the value is
still 6 you see the 6 here and then the
value is incremented so after line 15
the value becomes 7 so that's how we are
basically using the unary operators and
this is where I would like to end this
particular session in the next session
we will be discussing about other type
of operators which are comparison
operators and logical operators
Etc let's get started with equality and
relational operators when we talk about
relational operators they are sometimes
also called comparison operators and the
basic idea behind using these operators
is to compare things or compare the
values of variables or compare the
objects in Java so in Java if you need
to compare anything for example if you
want to compare if something is less
than the other thing or something is
greater than the other thing or
something is equal to the other thing
then you need to use the comparison
operators which are provided by Java
here you can see I have opened the
official Java docs and you can see a
bunch of comparison or relational
operators both of the terms are used
interchangeably some people call them
comparison operators and some people
call them relational operators so you
can see if I want to compare if an
object or a value is equal to another
value then I use the double equal sign
if I want to compare for non-equality I
will use exclamation with an equal to
which means not equal to if I want to do
a greater than comparison then I will
use the mathematics greater than symbol
if if I want to do the greater than
equal to or less than or less than equal
to they again follow the same kind of
terminology as we see in mathematics so
this is all we have in terms of the
relational operators so let's understand
the usage of these operators with the
help of some examples so as you can see
I have created a class here which is
called comparison operator there is a
public static wide main method inside
this class and this method has two
variables of integer type called value 1
and value 2 value 1 has the value 1 and
value 2 has the value 2 and then I am
trying to compare the value 1 and value
2 variables using the different
relational operators we just covered for
doing that I need to use a conditional
operator as well we will be covering
conditional operators in much much
detail in the upcoming lectures but for
now you can understand that when we talk
about conditional operators we talk
about if an else statement so f is again
a keyword in Java which can be used to
compare things and the syntax is very
straightforward you write the if keyword
and then you write the actual comparison
syntax or the actual comparison
expression so in the first example we
can see that I am writing a condition
which says evaluate if value 1 is equal
to Value 2 I should put a curly braces
around here you can see there are no
curly brushes here but that is for a
case when you have only one statement
under it but again I will cover this in
detail and I don't want to confuse the
audience here so I will just put curly
braces around all of these if statements
so that it becomes easy to interpret
what is actually going on in these code
blocks as we know that these curly
brushes are used to define a code block
so the first if block says compare if
the value 1 is equal to the value 2 if
yes then this condition will become 2
and the control of the program will go
at line number 10 and if this condition
is not true then the control will not go
inside 10 because this condition is
false so it will never go to line 10 and
it will move to line 11 or 12 instead
similarly the next condition is we are
comparing the value 1 is not equal to
Value 2. so this condition will only be
true if these two values are not equal
or unequal and if that is the case then
line 14 will execute it otherwise line
14 will not be executed similarly in
this condition I am saying compare if
value 1 is greater than value 2 or not
so if the actual value hold it by value
1 variable is greater than the value 2
variable then this condition will become
true and the line 18 will be executed
otherwise it will be skipped then
similarly at line 20 I am doing the
reverse I am comparing if value 1 is
less than equal less than value 2. if
that is the case then line 22 will be
executed otherwise it will be skipped
and At Last I am also showcase using an
example of less than equal to operator
that you put less than and equal to
together and again you compare the two
variables similarly you can also use
greater than equal to variable
comparison operator as well in this
example so we have an example of
equality not equal to greater than less
than and less than equal to let's run
this example to understand so for
running the example I will just right
click here go to run as and click on
Java application and we can see the
output here so as the value 1 holds the
value 1 and value 2 variable holds the
value 2 obviously 1 is not equal to 2 so
the first condition is not going to be
evaluated to true so line 10 will never
be executed because 1 is not equal to 2.
similarly if I talk about the next
condition which was if value 1 is not
equal to Value 2 then execute statement
14 and yes 1 is not equal to 2 that's
why we see this particular system dot
out dot println here we see this is
printed moving on is value 1 greater
than value 2 so is 1 greater than 2 no
it's not so line 18 will never be
executed then the next one is is value 1
less than value 2 so yes 1 is less than
2 so line 22 will be executed and we see
the line 22 output here
system.out.printerland output moving on
is 1 less than equal to 2 yes 1 is less
than equal to 2 so this particular
condition is also true and line 26 will
be executed and that's why we see this
here and that's all so we can see that
we are able to use these comparison or
relational operators to evaluate
different conditions and we write those
conditions using the if block and again
if you do not understand the if block
fully don't worry we will be covering
the if blocks in detail but the focus
here is in using the operators the not
equal to operators the greater than
equal to operators less than equal to
operators Etc so I hope these operators
give you better understanding of how to
use them now moving on to the next
section of this comparison operators
sometimes we also use some logical terms
to do the comparison for example if I
just move down here and I show you these
conditions here we call them conditional
operators conditional operators are used
to evaluate the conditions like and or
or and we use them in two two ways
either we can use it as Ampersand or
double Ampersand or we can use them as
pipe or double pipes so the idea is
basically to evaluate if one condition
is true and other condition is also true
or one condition is true or other
condition is true so whenever you want
to combine two conditions together
that's where you're going to use these
logical operators or conditional
operators you can also use the simple
English keywords like and or or you can
use the logical representation of these
keywords for example amperage Ampersand
or double Ampersand is equivalent to add
similarly double pipe is equivalent to
or so we can use these as well
interchangeably you can use either of
these uh operator representations to run
a conditional check in composition
meaning you can compare two conditions
saying okay if one is true and second is
true or one is true or second is true so
the whole focus is here in and and or
comparisons so let's switch back to the
IDE and let's look at an example of this
to understand this in detail so I will
again take the similar kind of example
again I have created two variables here
value one and value two value one has
value as 1 and second variable value 2
has value as 2 and then I am writing two
conditions this time in the same if
block you can see I am writing first
condition saying is value 1 equal to
equal to 1 and is value 2 also equal to
equal to 2 so this whole if condition is
only going to be true only if both of
the conditions are true that's the
property of and and will force that both
the conditions on the left hand side of
it and the right hand side of it hold
true and then only the whole expression
is going to hold true even if one of the
conditions evaluate to false the whole
if expression will evaluate to false
similarly for or conditions we again
write our left hand condition and a
right hand condition and in between we
write this double pipe we can also write
o r or in English that will also have
the same effect and this will evaluate
in a way that this whole expression this
whole expression will evaluate to true
if even a single condition either on
left side or right side of it becomes
true so or we'll just need one
expression to be true to make the whole
if condition true whereas and will force
both of the conditions to be 2 true to
make the whole expression as true so and
will require two truths to actually
become true but our condition will
require only one true to become true so
if we try to do uh understand this logic
here I am saying that if value 1 is
equal to equal to 1 which is correct and
value 2 is equal to equal to 2 then make
this condition as true so yes in this
case this condition will evaluate to
true because value 1 has value 1 1 and
value 2 has value as 2 so it will print
the line 10 whereas in the next
condition I am saying evaluate if value
1 is equal to equal to 1 or value 2 is
equal to equal to 1 so either of the
expression if becomes true either the
left side this expression or the right
side this expression either of the
expression becomes true this whole
condition will become true and line 14
will be executed line 14 will not be
executed only in a case when both of the
conditions here become false for example
if I write it like this then we know
that value 1 is not equal to 4 because
it's 1 and value 2 is not equal to 5
because it's true in that case both of
the expression will become false and
then line 14 will not be executed if I
write it like this then the left hand
expression is evaluated to true because
value 1 is 1 but the right hand
expression is false but it's fine the
line 14 will still be executed because
either of these side is true so the
whole expression becomes true similarly
here and will require both of the
Expressions to be true and if either of
them becomes false then the whole
expression becomes false so in the
current state line 10 will be executed
but if I change this to this then the
left hand side of this Ampersand will
evaluate to false and the whole
expression will evaluate to false in
that case and line 10 will never be
executed let's try to run all of these
scenarios to make a better understanding
of this so in this case both of the
conditions should work fine so I will
just right click and run as Java
application and yes we see this line 10
being printed and we also see this line
13 being printed so both of the lines
are printed correctly both of the
conditions are evaluating to true now
let's try to play around with it let me
change this value to 4 so now value 1
this left hand side expression is false
which should make the whole expression
as false and it should not print the
line 10 which is the statement so let's
run this program and see if that works
yes we see that this particular line is
not printed now because this whole
expression became false because the left
hand side of this expression became
false similarly in the r case either of
them has to have to be true you can see
currently value 2 equal to equal to 5
condition will actually result in a
false condition because this is not a
true value 2 is actually two not five
and still we see this particular
expression because either of them have
to be true if I make both of them as not
true now both of the conditions on the
left hand side of pipe and right hand
side of 5 are false conditions what will
happen now nothing will be printed the
reason for that is that value 1 is also
that this condition is also false and
value 2 condition is also false so the
whole expression became false and this
was already false so this is all I
wanted to cover in this lecture we
covered our about the comparison
operators and how to use them and in the
next lecture we are going to talk about
the bitwise operators let's get started
with bitwise operators now bitwise
operators are very less commonly used in
the Java programming World generally we
don't use them and generally we don't
need to use them you would generally use
them when you are doing really complex
bitwise calculation where you need to
manipulate the bits now what are
actually bits so if you remember when we
talked about the integer type variables
we talked about how much memory each of
the variable type or data type was going
to consume we said that this will take
one by height and this will take two
bytes Etc one byte is basically made up
of eight bits and bits are nothing but
positions where either a zero is stored
or one is stored actually the whole
machine will convert your whole program
ultimately in zeros and ones which are
nothing but bits so if you want to do
the manipulation at that level so now
you can understand you are you are
actually working at right at the Machine
level understanding so if you want to
manipulate the bits which are going to
be understood by the machine at that
level then you can use bitwise operators
but like I said generally we don't need
to use them now when we talk about
bitwise operators there are multiple
ways in which we can use them we can use
them with the standard and or or
operations if you remember we covered
this and or operations in the previous
lecture you see a difference here that
in case of and we are using a single
Ampersand for and not double Ampersand
this is one of the concept we which we
did not cover in the previous lecture
and I would just like to brief you about
this concept that if you use double
Ampersand that is also called a short
circuit operator and if you use a single
Ampersand that is called a standard
operator to build an understanding about
this I will just quickly recap of what
we covered in the last lecture and we'll
try to explain these Concepts as well so
let's go to The Logical operator demo
and here if you remember they were 2
ampersands and two pipes this is also a
valid expression a single Ampersand is
also a valid expression the only change
is in this case even if the left hand
condition evaluates to false still the
right hand condition will be evaluated
although we know that in case of and
either of the expression needs to be
false and the whole expression becomes
false so Java provides an advantage or
with that if you use double Ampersand
and if the left hand operation becomes
false then it will not cover the right
hand operation it will not even evaluate
the right hand operation because it
doesn't matter if the left hand
operation has already returned to false
or evaluated to false then no matter
whether right side is true or false the
whole expression is still going to be
false right that's the property of and
one of the side has to be false and the
whole expression becomes false so why
why evaluate two sides why waste the
memory in evaluating the right side when
the left side has already turned as
false Java takes advantage of that and
that's why if you use double Ampersand
you save a bit of processing power of
your computer by just evaluating the
left hand condition and if the left hand
condition is false it will skip
evaluating the right hand condition and
just make the whole expression false but
if you use this a single n percent then
both side of the expression will be
evaluated irrespective of their output
so in this case even if the left hand
expression is false it is still going to
evaluate the right side expression and
similarly it works for the or case as
well in this case in our case as we know
if one of the condition is true the
whole condition becomes true the whole
expression becomes true so if the left
hand side becomes true and if you use a
single pipe then it will still evaluate
the right hand side but if you use
double pipe like this then if the left
hand side becomes true then it knows
that it does not matter if the right
hand side becomes true or false because
ultimately the whole expression is going
to be true if either of the side is true
so if the left hand side is already true
it will not evaluate the right hand side
and it will say the whole expression is
true that's why you see the single
Ampersand being used for bit wise just
to explain why it why it is used and how
it is used for all operations in bitwise
you use this cap or whatever you want to
call it as and for the inclusive bitwise
or opera or operation we are going to
use a single pipe you also use some
shift operations where you shift the
value of bit of a particular variable to
either left or right again these are
again very complex calculations if you
want to use that please read about this
and use that but in the in today's demo
what we are going to cover is the and
and or examples of bitwise operations
so here I have again created a class
called bitwise operator I have a public
static void main method I have two
variables here which are int a equal to
5 and int b equal to 7. now these 5 and
7 are actually stored as bits as zeros
and ones in the computer's memory so how
they are actually stored they are stored
in a standard bit representation which
you may have studied in your mathematics
if to give your recap this 5 will
basically be written in a memory as this
0 1 0 1 and it starts from here 2 raised
to power 0 into 1 becomes 1 2 raised to
power 1 into 0 becomes 0 2 raised to
power 2 into 1 becomes 4 and 2 raised to
power 3 into 0 becomes 0 so 4 0 plus 4
plus 0 plus 1 becomes 5 and that's how 5
is displayed to you similarly for 7 2
raised to power 0 into 1 is 1 the plus 2
raised to power 1 into 1 is 2 so 1 plus
2 3 plus 2 raised to power 2 into 1
which is 4 so 1 plus 2 plus 4 7 and 2
raised to power 3 into 0 is 0 so 0 plus
4 plus 2 plus 1 which is 7 and that's
how this 7 is built and stored and now
if you try to do this if you try to
write this condition you can also write
the condition into a system dot out dot
println block and it will basically
evaluate this condition so now if you
say A and B in this case this is going
to do a bit wise operation because this
is bitwise operand it is going to do a
bit wise operation and the what would be
the result if you do an and on this so
again use the same logic as if in case
of and if one is false then the whole
expression is false so 0 and 0 becomes 0
1 and 1 becomes 1 0 and 1 becomes 0
because 0 means false and 1 means true
so if either of them is false the whole
evaluation becomes false so that's why 0
or and 1 becomes 0 and 1 and 1 is always
one the value of this is again 5 as we
already have evaluated similarly if you
do a bit wise or and if we do this again
we are doing an R operation so 0 or 0 or
basically false or false becomes false
true or true becomes true false or true
should be true because one of them needs
to be true so this is false but this is
true so the whole value becomes true and
the finally true or true is also true so
this is the final bitwise or result and
if we convert this into an integer
representation that becomes 7 because 2
raised to power 0 into 1 is 1 2 raised
to power 1 into 1 is 2 so 2 plus 1 3
plus 2 raised to power 2 into 1 which is
4 so 4 plus 2 plus 1 which is 7 and plus
2 raised to power 3 into 0 which is 0 so
0 plus 4 plus 2 plus 1 becomes 7 and
that's how you get actually seven so
let's see if we get 5 or 7 in this bit
wise operation yes we can see the values
as 5 and 7 so this is a bit wise
operation happening similarly you can
also use the shift operations where in
case if you're using the this particular
kind of representation or this
particular kind of representation they
are called bits they are called left
shift and right shift operations so if
you use this in front of a variable then
for example this one will be shifted
here and this 0 will be shifted here and
this one will be shifted here so that's
how the whole value is going to shift
whole bits are going to shift one by one
towards left similarly if you are using
the right shift then all the bits are
going to be shifted towards right by one
bit that's the whole concept of left
shift and right shift bitwise operations
and if you want to know more about this
please read some official examples from
the Java Doc and some other examples
available on the internet to build an
understanding on this so this is all I
wanted to cover in this lecture so in
the next session we are going to talk
about the control flow statements like
if else Etc let's get started with
control flow statements so what are
control flow statements and why do we
need them control flow statements are
the ones which can help you control and
Define the flow of execution in your
program now why do we need them is
because if we want to evaluate some
conditions or we want to create some
branches of execution saying that if
this condition becomes true do this and
if this condition becomes false do that
so you can see there are two different
branches of execution of a program in
this kind of approach and that's where
control flow statements can help us
there are lot of different types of
control flow statements like if then
else and switch and for and while and do
while and we are going to cover all of
them in detail in this series so let's
get started with the first one which is
the if statement we covered briefly
about this when we talked about
operators and I promised you guys that I
will be covering this in detail and this
is the session where we'll be we will go
deeper into this concept as we have
already understood that if condition is
basically used to evaluate a condition
if it is true or false the result of an
if statement will always have only two
values it can either have a true value
or it can have a false value there is no
other possibility or there is no other
value of an if statement or as an if
expression now like I explained if you
want want to do a simple programming
execution where you say if a particular
condition becomes true do this and if
this becomes false then do that it means
you need to write this else condition as
well that if this doesn't hold true what
do I do and how do I write that so let's
understand that with the help of an
example for this particular example I've
created a class and there is a public
static void main method which is the
entry point of this program's execution
I have a variable which is called test
score this is an integer variable with
the value 76 and I have a care variable
which is grade basically what I am doing
that based on the test score marks I am
trying to define the grades which a
student will get so for that I have
built a condition here so you can see it
starts with if which is a keyword then
you put these standard braces for
brackets and you write your condition
inside it in this case I'm writing the
condition saying that if test score is
greater than equal to 90 then the
student should get and grade A so here
I've defined this grid variable and here
I am just assigning the value to the
grade variable at line 11 if the test
score is greater than 90 the grade
should be a but what if the score is not
90. what if this condition becomes false
and you want to do something in that
case you can write this else block here
we call this else block so you write
else as the keyword you start the curly
braces and then you define the grade if
the score is not greater than 90 what
should be the grade of the student so in
this case we are saying the grade is f
so if we try to run this example in our
in our mind we see that the value is of
the test score is 76 so 76 is not
greater than equal to 90. so this
particular condition will not be true so
line 11 will not be executed but in
instead else block will be executed
because if the condition goes false then
else block should be executed as per
Java so this block will be executed and
grade will get a value of F and then we
are printing this grid value by just
writing a
system.out.println a string plus the
value so let's run this particular
program and see what happens
we get a grade equal to F here in this
Swiss out or system.out.print element
because this condition was false so the
control the flow of the control of the
program went to line 12 and then to line
30 because this was the else block so
this is one understanding where we can
write an if and else logic you in some
cases you might not need an else block
so else block is not mandatory it's an
optional block if you want to remove
this and if you just want to do a sys
out here that is also fine this out
means system dot out dot println for
shorthand we sometimes call it as this
out so you can do something here as well
if you don't need Dell's block if you
need Dell's block feel free to write it
but this is an optional block but in
some cases your conditions will be more
complicated than just a single condition
if we try to understand it from a real
world example in real world you will not
have only two grades as a and F you will
have more grades right A B C D so and so
forth so what are you going to do in
that case for that kind of case Java
provides us with an keyword which is
called else if else if is just a
continuation of if saying that okay if
this condition doesn't hold true
evaluate the next one with an else if so
I've commented out this code let me put
this code back into its place and then
we will walk through this code to
understand it okay so I have put the
code back to where it should be and this
is how it looks like so let's just walk
through this the line 10 and 11 doesn't
change it's still the same but then I
have added some additional conditions
saying that okay if the score is greater
than equal to 90 the grade should be a
but if the score is not greater than 90
but greater than equal to 80 then the
grade should be B similarly if the score
is not even greater than 80 but greater
than equal to 70 then the grade should
be C similarly if the score is not even
greater than equal to 70 but greater
than equal to 60 which means basically
between 60 to 70 then the grade should
be D and if the score is even below 60
then the grade should be F so you can
see I have basically defined the whole
Logic for defining the grades here and
it always works in a top-down approach
one by one the way in the sequence in
which you will Define the else if block
will be the sequence in which they will
be executed so after the condition at
line 10 and if this condition fails line
12 will be naturally executed if this
condition also fails line 14 will be
executed and so on so forth it will
never be the case that if this condition
fails then suddenly line 16 is and then
again line 12 is executed it will always
work in a line by line fashion so make
sure whenever you are using the l-shift
statements write it in a sequence in
which you want the natural program to be
executed so this is all we have here and
now let's try to run this example let me
just bring the system.out.printel in a
lineup save this file right click run as
Java application so we see the value is
grid equal to C which means this
particular code block was actually
executed only this condition held true
now now let's try to understand how this
happened the value was 76 so 76 greater
than 90 no this condition becomes false
so line 11 is never executed it
naturally goes to line 12 because that's
where we have defined the next else if
block is 76 greater than equal to 80 no
it's not so line 12 conditional also
becomes false line 13 never gets
executed and the control shifts to line
14 and there we have the condition
saying that is 76 greater than equal to
70 yes this condition is true so the
line 15 gets executed and once this
condition gets true none of the further
conditions will be executed because you
only need one true statement one true
execution in the whole if else if block
if that one code block gets true that
code block is executed and then the
execution jumps out of the ills if else
if blocks and it will directly go to
line 22 and it will execute that had it
been the case that this particular block
was also evaluated to false it would go
to line 16 and if this was also false it
would go to the block which is else
block let's see that let's make this
value as 56. so now 56 is not greater
than 70 so line 15 will ever be executed
because this condition will evaluate to
false 56 is greater than 60 no so this
will also be false and ultimately the
grade should fall to else block where we
are assigning the grid as F let's see
yes we get the grid F because ultimately
this block was executed because all of
the above conditions evaluated to false
so this is all I wanted to cover in this
if else if demo there is another edition
of another way of writing if statements
which we call as nested if where we have
an if block inside an if block inside an
if block and so on so forth how do we
write that and how does the control
flows in that kind of an execution we
will cover that in the next session
let's get started with using nested if
statements in Java now in the previous
lecture we saw how we can use an if else
block and also an if else if else block
but there is another case where we can
use these if statements and that is when
you have nested if blocks when and would
you use it let's take an example let's
say you have multiple conditions to
check on a particular program and where
the output of the first condition is the
input of the second condition and the
output of the second condition is the
input to the third condition and so on
so forth if you have that kind of
situation you can write it in a nested
if statement kind of block so let's
understand this with the help of an
example as you can see I have opened an
example here which is about nested if
statements I have created a class which
which is named as nested if demo and I
have created a public static void main
method inside this particular class and
now I have declared an integer variable
with the value 50 then I am checking the
first condition saying if I equal to
equal to 50 if that condition is true
then I will check the next condition
which is if I is less than 75 and then I
am adding one more hypothetical
condition saying if this is true then
also check if I is less than 55 so you
can see if I equal to 50 holds true then
only this condition will be executed
similarly if I is less than 75 then only
this condition will be executed so they
are dependent upon each other this
condition block is dependent upon the
previous block to be true and this if
condition block is dependent upon this
if block to be true if either of these
if blocks don't go through the next
subsequent nested if block will not be
executed so in this case I am checking
it for first equality condition saying
if the value is equal to 50 then execute
this statement at line number 10 then
check if I is less than 75 if that is
also true execute the statement at light
number 12 and then if I is also less
than 55 then also execute line number
14. I can also add an else block as well
anywhere in this nested hierarchy if I
want to if I add an else block here that
else block will be corresponding to this
block if I add an else block here and
that else block will be corresponding to
this if block and if I add an else block
here then that else block will be
corresponding to this particular if
block so you can also use those else if
and else blocks as well with nested if
blocks and make it as complicated as you
want it to be so that's about this
program and let's see if we run this
program what output do we get and let's
interpret that output so I'll just right
click run as Java program and I see some
output in the console first I get I is
50 so line number 10 gets printed
because I is 50 then I also see the next
line output as I is smaller than 75 it
means this condition was also true
because 50 is less than 75 so line 12
also got executed and then I'm checking
if I is less than 55 so yes 50 is less
than 55 so line 14 also gets executed
and we get this statement on the console
so this was a simple way to see how we
can implement the nested if conditions
now we are also going to talk about
another concept which is used in writing
the if conditional blocks which is
called ternary operators so ternary
operators are used as a shorthand of
writing if else block as you can see
that these if blocks are quite verbose
we have to write a lot of code to
actually write some conditions in this
case I'm executing three conditions but
the code is almost seven lines or eight
lines so we will see how we can simplify
this if we use a ternary operator and
for that I have created another class
which is called ternary operator demo
and this particular class again has a
public static void main which is the
entry point of this particular program
and then I have declared couple of
variables first is int a equal to 1 and
second one is int b equal to two I have
also delayed cleared a result variable
and we will see how we can use this
result variable and at line 10 I have
written my if else expression so you can
see this if else expression doesn't look
like the one which we have seen before
so let's understand how do we write it
if you're trying to write an if else
expression with ternary expressions or
ternary statements then the first thing
which you need to understand is the
structure of it so here at first you
will specify the actual condition which
you want to test in your if block so
this is my condition then after that
condition you are going to put a
question mark and after the question
mark you are going to put the actual
result which you want to be executed if
this condition becomes true so if the if
condition becomes true what do you want
to do whatever is that you will write it
here and then if the condition becomes
false then the logic should go into the
else block and the else logic should
come after this colon so all you need to
remember is this question mark and the
this colon before the question mark you
are going to write the condition after
the question mark you are going to write
the statement which is going to be
executed if this if condition becomes
true and after the colon you are going
to write the else block condition which
is going to be executed if this
condition becomes false another thing to
notice is that ternary operators can be
used only in cases when you have only
one statement to execute in if block and
one statement to execute in else block
it cannot be more than one statements so
instead of this you can also write
system.out.printl in here which will
also be fine if I just write this system
dot out dot print not print F but I want
to write println so I'll just write
println you can also do this this is
also fine you don't need to store the
result obviously but but you can also
write this condition in a way but this
all this only has to be a single
statement it cannot be more than one
statement because this expression can
only hold one statement at a time so use
it in situations where you have to check
a condition and do something in the if
block which is only one statement and
again one statement in the else block
the same expression can also be written
in a verbose if else way in which we
have been seeing it before and we'll
also I will also show that to you and
here where this A and B is going this is
getting stored in this variable called
result so if this if condition holds
true then the result is a and this is
going to be stored here and if it is
going into the else block then B is
going to be stored in the result block
let's run this program so we can see we
get the value 1 because we have set the
condition as a less than b so yes 1 is
less than 2 so this particular statement
gets executed and this value gets stored
here in the result variable so that's
how you can use the ternary operators to
write shorthand if else statements the
same expression can also be written in a
verbose way for example you can write it
in this way saying if a is less than b
then result equal to a else result equal
to B this code has exactly the same
effect as this one line of code so you
can see this is this is pretty simple to
write pretty short to write the code
which I'm writing here in four lines can
be written here in one line and that's
the power of ternary operators so this
is all I wanted to cover in today's
session so we talked about nested if
statements and The ternary Operators
here how to use them in the next session
we are going to discuss about switch
case statements let's get started with
using switch statements in Java so let
us first understand why do we need
switch statements generally whenever you
want to check a condition you can use an
if else block but what if you have
multiple conditions to check what if you
have so many possible execution paths
that it becomes two verbose to write it
into an if else kind of block what if
you have to check on constant values of
certain Expressions how do you do that
it becomes even more challenging and the
code becomes even more verbose so in
such cases switch statement can be used
in which you can write switch statement
to have as many possible execution paths
as you want and it will work with
constant values as well so let's
understand this with the help of an
example as how and why will we use the
switch statements so for that I have
created this class which is called
switch demo and it also has a public
static void main method which is the
entry point and in this program what I'm
doing is I'm trying to accept a number
as the month number in the program and
then with that particular number I'm
trying to print the corresponding
month's name so that's the logic pick a
month number and you should get the
month's actual name so now in this case
you can you can imagine there will be at
least 12 if else if blocks which is a
long line of if else statements at the
same time if we try to do this for other
conditions where the value is constant
please understand that the value of
month is going to be constant it's going
to be the same number so it's not
similar to you evaluating a condition
it's similar to you evaluating a
condition to a particular constant value
imagine if you have to do some sort of a
classification of employees in higher
salaries and lower salaries and there
are hundreds of salary bans in the
company so are you going to write 100 if
else Logics that is going to take a long
time and then what if new bands get new
bands get introduced then it gets even
more complex so we will use switch case
statements in cases where there are lots
of if else conditions and the expression
evaluates to a constant value remember
in the if else cases the expression
evaluates to a Boolean value so here I'm
supplying the month value as 6 then I'm
also creating a string month month
string variable just to print or store
the name of the month and then the way
you write the switch statement is to
write the switch keyword and then in the
brackets you supply the month integer
value and then you start writing your
conditions so you can see you write the
case as keyword and then you write the
number or the possible values this
particular variable or this particular
expression can hold so all the possible
values this particular expression can
hold will be written individually as
cases so case equal to 1 here 1 means
the value of month is 1 in that case the
month string which we created here shell
store January and then we see a
statement called break so break is again
a keyword in Java and this keyword has a
special meaning it has a special usage
you will use the keyword break to
abruptly break the control of execution
from the current code block and the code
block is identified with curly braces so
here you can see the curly brace starts
from here and it ends down to line
number 51 at here so the moment your
Java program is going to encounter this
particular statement it is going to jump
out of the current code block execution
and continue thereafter that's the basic
logic and usage of break statement so
use it whenever you want to skip the
rest of the code after the break
statement if you don't want to execute
the rest of the code you will right
break and the moment the Java program
sees this particular statement it will
jump out of the current code block
specified by the curly braces and will
resume execution after the code block so
in this case it will resume the
execution after the line 21 that's the
usage and the meaning of this expression
called break so in this case we are
saying that if the month value is 1
which we denoted as here case 1 then
store the value of the month string as
January and break out of this particular
code block because we don't need to
execute any further we have found a
match then another case would be if the
month value is 2 so you write case which
is a keyword and then the exact
expression value the constant value
which is 2 and if that's the case then
one string becomes February and again
you break because in this particular
case there will only be one condition
true at a time there will never be a
case that month with the value 2 will
have two meanings we'll have two month
names a month with the value 2 will
always have a meaning called February it
will never have two meanings or two
month names attached to the same integer
value and that's why you do not want to
execute any further and and that's why
you write this break statement if you do
not write this break statement it is
going to evaluate all of the cases one
by one even if the cases are not going
to be true but it is going to waste lot
of processing time evaluating all the
case conditions which you have written
here which does not make sense because
we know that only one condition at a
time can be true here because we are
evaluating and checking for a constant
value which is an integer value so
that's the reason we put a break in each
case if intentionally if you want to
check multiple cases do not put a break
statement but the program can become
really confusing in that case so take
your wise call so here we put a break in
each case similarly case 3 the month
string becomes March case 4 the month
string becomes April case 5 becomes May
case 6 becomes June case 7 we have one
string as July case 8 month string is
August case 9 we store the month string
as September case 10 as October case 11
is November and case 12 as December
after that you will also see an
interesting block called default this is
the another capability of switch
statement that what if none of the above
conditions hold true what if we specify
a value which is not between 1 and 12
and it will not match any of the cases
which we saw just above and if you want
to execute sarcode in that case if none
of the conditions matches you may want
to execute some default execution also
in such cases you are going to use
default default is the code block which
will be executed if none of the case
matches so here you can see that if none
of the cases match then we are going to
store the value of month string variable
as invalid month and then we'll
eventually break out and once we break
out of this program we just want to
print the month string that's all we are
doing in this program that we take an
integer value as the month number and
then we print the corresponding month
name here by looking at the case blocks
and we also default Define our default
case block if none of the conditions
hold true so let's run this program we
have specified the value as 6 which
should result in the month name as June
and yes we can see we get June let's
change the value and let's put the value
as 10 and see what do we get so right
click run as Java application and we got
October yes exactly correct let's put an
invalid value as 13 and let's see what
happens now now we get invalid month so
our default code block just got executed
because we entered a value which is not
matching any of the case conditions
which we have specified so this is how
you are going to use the switch and case
statements while writing your conditions
whenever your condition evaluates to
multiple constant values remember the
the key here is to understand if you
your expression is evaluating to
multiple constant values which do not
change and in those cases using a switch
case block is a better idea than writing
if else statements so that is all what
we are going to cover in today's session
and in the next session we are going to
understand something about two
dimensional arrays and multi-dimensional
arrays as well let's get started with
understanding arrays in detail we have
been talking about arrays throughout
this course of java in the previous
sessions as well and we have covered
some basic understanding of how to
create arrays how to declare them how to
fill values in the array and how do we
print the array with positions as well
as the array as whole but whatever
examples which we took previously were
one dimensional arrays because arrays
can have more than one Dimensions as
well you can create a one-dimensional
array you can create a two dimensional
array you can create even a
three-dimensional array and you can go
up to as many dimensions as you can
handle in your Java program so it
depends upon the kind of complexity you
want to have in your program and the
kind of values the kind of structure you
are going to store in your arrays and
based on that need you can choose
whether you want to use a 1D array or
one dimensional array or a 2d array or a
3D array and so on in these sessions we
are going to talk about 1D arrays 2D
arrays and 3D arrays and after that
we'll leave up to you to try out more
dimensionals if you want to we have
already covered the basic array
structures which were one dimensional
arrays so I will just give you a quick
walkthrough of how we actually handled
one-dimensional arrays so this is a
sample program to demonstrate one
dimensional arrays if you remember this
is how we use to create arrays we write
the data type of the array and then we
write the square boxes which denote that
this is an integer array data type we
assign a variable to this and then we
initialize the error a with a size 4 so
new is the keyword which is used to
initialize anything in Java and we are
going to use this heavily when we talk
about classes and objects and even
collections literally any object which
you want to create in Java requires a
new keyword so here I'm writing new and
then int 4 which means create an array
of size 4 and then I'm filling the value
of the four positions which I have
created as part of this array and if you
remember when we create these kind of
arrays we store them in a zero index
based position the first value gets
stored at 0th index position and then so
on so forth so it will always start from
0 and never start from one remember that
and after that we just print all the
values of individual positions of the
elements in the array and if I just run
this program all of the elements of this
particular array should be printed one
by one so if I just show the full
console of the output we can see that
element and index 0 was 10 element and
index 1 was 20 element at index 2 was 30
and element at index 3 was 40. so this
was just a quick refresher of how one
dimensional arrays can be written and
whenever you declare a very simplistic
array it will generally be a one
dimensional array now let's look at the
two dimensional arrays and how do we
write them when do we need them for that
I have created another example which is
says two dimensional array I just
created a class and it has a public
static void main method and I've created
a two dimensional array this time so
let's understand this two dimensional
array in a bit detail and when do we
need that generally you would need to
use two dimensional arrays whenever you
are trying to do any Matrix calculations
if you if you understand what do you
mean by matrix it's basically a two by
two structure which stores the values in
the form of rows and columns so imagine
a table of two rows and two columns then
it will be a two by two Matrix so if you
want to store that particular table in a
Java program you would need to store
that as a matrix as a two dimensional
Matrix rows being the one dimensional
and column being the other dimension and
that's what we are doing here and if you
want to store that 2D Matrix in a Java
program the approach and the procedure
for that is pretty similar to how you
create a one-dimensional array with
slight changes the first change is
instead of a single square bracket you
are going to write two square brackets
because it is a two dimensional array so
remember the number of square brackets
you are going to put while initializing
and declaring the array is the number of
Dimensions which your array is going to
have since this is a two dimensional
array example that's why you see two
brackets here if this was a three
dimensional array example you will see
three array three square brackets here
and so on so forth so that's the first
part of it second part to understand is
to how to store the data remember I told
you always imagine the structure of rows
and columns whenever you are trying to
store a two-dimensional array in Java so
what are rows and what are values and
how do you represent them while you
declare and initialize a two-dimensional
array so you start with the curly braces
as the normal 1D array but inside the
curly braces you create nested curly
braces blocks you can see three blocks
here they start with their own curly
brace and end with their own then this
curly brush starts here and ends here
and then this curly brace starts here
and ends here idea is that you provide
this outer curly braces to define the
overall structure and then inside each
of the curly brushes is going to
represent a row in your two dimensional
array so each of these values these
blocks is going to represent a row so I
can say that this this is the first row
this is the second row and this is the
third row and if I try to visualize it
in terms of columns then this is the
first row First Column first row second
column First Row Third column similarly
second row First Column second row
second column second row third column
and third row First Column third row
second column and third row third column
so individual values are going to be
represented as columns and the whole
curly braces is going to be represented
as arrays that's the basic mental idea
or mental image you should have while
declaring a two dimensional arrays
remember to declare the rows inside the
nested curly braces and whatever
elements you have will automatically be
indexed as columns one other thing to
remember that since this is an array
data structure everything starts from 0
and nothing starts from one so this will
be row 0 this this will be Row 1 and
this will be Row 2 I'm talking about the
position we can still call it as first
row second row and third row but the
position of this particular row element
is 0 the position of this particular row
element is 1 and this particular row
element is 2. similarly for column as
well this is column 0 column 1 and
column two similarly column 0 column one
and column two and so on so forth once
you understand this data structure well
and you have defined it correctly then
everything should fall in place if you
want to do a matrix addition or if you
want to do a matrix multiplication for a
DOT product all of the kind of
calculations can be performed using the
2D array concept here in this program
what I am doing is I am printing the
values of this particular 2D array into
a matrix style and you see some strange
code here which is for ETC don't worry
about this I am going to cover in detail
what this four means and how do you
write this for now what we can
understand that we just want to print
this you might not need to print this in
your Java programs when you write a
production grade application but you
might want to do manipulations on these
arrays as metrics maybe you want to
create a transpose of a matrix or you
want to do a DOT product or addition or
subtraction or whatever be your use case
in this case just for demonstration
purpose I am printing the values as rows
and columns nothing else so this all of
this code from line 8 to line 14 or in
fact line 13 is just showing how to
print the values you can see some system
dot out and you can see some construct
here and like I said don't worry about
this I will cover this in detail let's
run this program and see if my Java
array is stored correctly and how can I
represent this so you can see I have
represented it in a style of a 2d Matrix
where this is the first row this is the
second row and this is the third row
similarly this is the First Column
containing the value value 237 so column
0 will have value 2 and column 1 will
have this value 3 and column 2 will have
this value 7 for row 0. let me also do
something here which can help you
understand this concept better let me do
a system dot out Dot println and let's
print an individual value because like I
said the for Loop can be confusing here
to understand so let's say I want to
print ARR of 0th row First Column and
see what kind of values do we get let me
comment this code comment is control
backslash and this code will be
commented and this code will not be
executed and now only line 15 will be
executed instead of the four block so if
I run this I get the value 7 so row 0
and First Column row 0 First Column is
seven let's try with one one I want to
print the row at zero one position
remember not the first row but the one
position row which is basically
technically the second row so second row
second column and see what kind of
values value do I get in this case I get
6 so second row second column similarly
if you change this value to 2 then third
row second column which should point to
four yes we get four similarly you can
write a value here as 0 and you can
write a value here as let's say 2 this
will print the 0th row and the second
column so similarly whatever kind of
value you want to write you or you want
to access you can access it in this
fashion and remember the column and row
indexes will always start from zero so
this is a simple demonstration of how
you can use two dimensional arrays and
in this session we also did a refresher
of one dimensional arrays so that's all
for this session and in the next session
we are going to be discussing how we can
Define three dimensional arrays and
we'll also see an example of it let's
get started with how to create and use a
three dimensional array or how to go
about using multi-dimensional arrays in
Java so as you can see from this image
we talked about 1D array which is having
just one axis then we talked about 2D
arrays in the last session where we had
rows and columns basically an X axis and
a y axis and then we can also have a 3D
array which will have three axises which
will have an x-axis a y-axis and also a
z-axis think of a simple box which every
box in this world will always have at
least three dimensions and from from
here you can go even build more complex
arrays which can have four dimensions or
five Dimensions or as many dimensions as
you want it to have and today we are
going to look at an example of how can
we build a 3D array and how do we access
those elements but this picture is just
to show you the mental model of when you
will be creating a 3D array so for
example generally an image data is
stored in in three dimensions so you can
you might want to store the image data
into a 3D array and there can be many
other use cases in the mathematical and
research computational use cases where
you might want to use a 3D array so but
remember there's an x-axis there's a
y-axis and then there is a third axis
which is called the z-axis so let us
look at a Java program to understand how
we can build a three-dimensional array
and for that I have created this class
which is called multi-dimensional array
it has a entry point method which is the
public static white main method and then
I have created an integer array and this
time instead of one or two square
brackets I have three square brackets
and if you remember I mentioned this in
the previous session as well the number
of square brackets which you're going to
put while initializing the array is the
number of dimensions of the array and
since in this particular program I am
going to demonstrate a three-dimensional
array that's why you see three square
blocks boxes let me just minimize this
yep so we have three square boxes here
and we have created the variable name as
ARR or short form as array then we start
with the outer post curly braces as is
then we put another curly braces which
starts from here and it ends here then
another set of curly brace which starts
from here and and here so this is the
this is the First Dimension this is the
second dimensions and these are the
third dimensions that's how you are
going to define the different dimensions
remember this is the First Dimension
when the first curly brace starts then
you have the second dimension which
covers this hole and this hole and then
you have third dimension which are these
so that's how you are going to visualize
and and put the three dimensions in use
by while declaring a three-dimensional
array and the values work in the same
fashion it's it's a zero index based
position so since we do not have an
official name for the third dimension so
I'm just gonna use x axis y axis and Z
axis to refer to the three axises so
this would be X of 0 this would be y of
0 and this would be Z of zero similarly
X of 1 y of 1 and Z of 1 and so on so
forth so now if I try to access the
value which is at 0th X position first y
position and second Z position what's
the value do we get here let's run this
program and understand and interpret the
output okay so when we ran this program
we got the output as 11. so let's
understand this output so when we say
the zeroth position on X the first
position on Y and the second position on
Z so this is the zeroth position on X
and this is the first position on Y and
then this element is 0 1 2 is the second
position on the Z axis so to to describe
it in a nutshell this defines the x axis
so we have two elements on the x axis
here this one and this one then we have
two elements on the y axis on each x
axis so this is one this is two on the
first x axis and this is one and this is
2 on the second y second x axis so 2X
and 2y and then on the Z axis I have
three elements each so hope this helps
you understand and visualize this so x
axis and this one is other x axis and
then Y axis y axis and then in elements
inside this are Z axis so I'm saying 0
with x axis in this block first on the y
axis which is this block and then second
element or the Z or second position
element on this particular ax in this
particular block which is 11 and that's
why we get 11. if I print 0 let's say I
change this particular value as 1. so
now the output should be coming from
this side so second X position because
it's one second y position so this will
go here and then the two position which
is the third element of the Z axis which
is 13. so let's see if we get 13 yes we
get 13 here so this is just to show you
how you can interpret this this
particular array and always be mindful
of how you are structuring this array if
your structure is gone wrong then your
program will become useless and it will
give you lot of unpredictable outputs
which might not make sense and which may
introduce errors in your program so be
very careful how you define the
structure of the elements here that's
the key and after that you just need to
understand the x-axis the y-axis and the
z-axis always remember all the accesses
start from 0 so when I say 2 I'm
basically referring to the third element
and not the second element so this is
all I wanted to cover in this particular
session where we describe how we can use
a three-dimensional array and from here
you can go to any lens like I said you
can add more square brackets here and go
to four dimension or five dimension or
six Dimension but remember the more
Dimensions you add the more complexity
of the program will be having the
program will become more and more
difficult to debug and understand so
always try to take a wise call as to how
many dimensions you want to use in your
array and that's it for this particular
session in the next session we are going
to talk about the different Loop
statements in Java let's get started
with today's topic which is about how to
use do while Loops now in the previous
session we covered the usage of while
Loops but we have another type of while
loop which is called a do while loop so
let's understand when do we need that
and how do you actually use that let me
switch to the Java documentation and if
I can find some syntax of it as well yep
so as you can see here if I just
highlight this portion this is how you
actually write a do while statement
block so you write do you start a code
block you write some executable
statements and then after the code block
ends you write a while expression and
end it with semicolon this is the syntax
basically it starts with do to our curly
braces some executable statements are
while block or a while statement
basically with an expression ending with
a semicolon let's understand this with
the help of a program to understand the
structure better so for this I have
created a sample program here which is
called do while demo again having a
public static void main method and it
has a variable which is count and it is
initialized as one then I write do I
write this code block or the curly
braces and then I am just printing the
value of count then I am incrementing
the value of count and then I am writing
a condition which says while count is
less than 10 and semicolon if you
compare this with the previous demo we
ran if I just put them side by side we
had while condition statement and and
the state change condition here we have
do statement condition change statement
and then we check the condition at the
end so the idea is that if you have a
use case where before you even evaluate
the condition you want to print
something even before you evaluate the
condition if you want to do something in
that case you will use the do while loop
even before the while actual while loop
starts if you want to execute a
statement you will use do while loop for
example if you want to print the initial
value of the count even before the
condition checks then you can use do
while loop if that is not your use case
you can use a simple while loop which is
described here in this program so coming
back to the do while so I say do and
then I am saying print this particular
statement without checking anything this
condition will be executed for the first
time without any condition check at all
this will just work as is like a normal
Java statement after that I am
incrementing the value of the count and
then I am checking the condition so
remember when this particular the
condition is being checked the first
increment has already happened but in
the while case we did the comparison
before even the first increment the
first comparison happened with the
original value of count but here the
first comparison is happening with the
incremented value of the count hope you
get the difference in a better context
now that you will use this when you want
to do some write some initialization
code before you actually hit the
condition so this condition will be
evaluated with 2 less than 10 and then
the value will be printed let's print
this example and we'll also try to play
around with this example a bit more to
bring to build our understanding better
if I run this program there is no
difference in output if you compare this
with the previous program we ran for the
while so it prints the count value so
this is coming here then it increments
the value then it checks the condition
saying is 2 less than 10 yes that holds
true if that holds true it it will go
back to statement number nine again
print this again do an increment on the
count and again check the condition with
the updated value of the count which
will say 3 less than 10 now similarly
print the value increment check this
will continue to happen till this
particular condition becomes false and
once this condition is false it will
exit out of this whole do while loop and
it will go to the line number 12 and if
you have any statement written there you
can that statement will be executed in
this case so let's try to change some
values here and let's see if if we can
make sense of this program if we change
the value let's see if I put 11 here
what will happen now let's run this
program you will say the now you will
see that this particular output is
displayed which says count is 11. so
what happened here that count was 11 it
entered the do while block it went to
this particular statement which said
count is 11 then it incremented the
value so the value became 12 and
obviously 12 is not less than 10 so it
did not print it again it only printed
once even if the first time the
condition was checked the first
condition execution itself resulted in
false still line number nine got
successfully printed and that's the
whole that's the whole idea behind using
the do wild what if I change this value
to 10 let's see what happens and after
that we'll run one more combination to
just make it more interesting This Time
Again count is 10 line number 10 will be
printed as count is 10 then at line
number 10 the count is incremented to 11
and 11 is not less than 10 so in this
case the loop ends and it will move out
now what happens if I do this if I say
less than equal to here let's run this
program and interpret the output now
again only one statement is printed
because in this case the count is 10 10
is printed here and and we are saying 10
plus 1 11 11 is still not less than
equal to 10 and that's why the loop just
exits let's make it 9 and see what
happens now you see two values so count
is 9 it enters the do while loop goes to
statement number nine prints the current
value of count which is 9 then
increments the value to 10 then at line
number 11 this while statement is
executed and the condition is checked is
10 less than equal to 10 yes 10 is not
less than but 10 is equal to 10 so this
condition will hold true it will go back
here print count is 10 May count 11
again check the condition is 11 less
than equal to 10 no it's not and then
the condition will return to false and
loop will be exited so hope this will
give you a better understanding now
since we rank different permutations and
combinations of the values and we saw
when this will be executed and when this
will not be executed but the the bottom
line is very straightforward that
whenever you want to write some
pre-processing logic even before
checking the very first condition of
your Loop then in that case you will be
using a do while loop otherwise a normal
while loop or a for Loop will have
absolutely work fine so that's the
takeaway I would like you to take away
from this particular session and that's
all for this particular session we
talked about do while and we also try to
give you some sort of a comparison
between while loops and do while Loops
in the next session we are going to be
discussing about for Loops in detail
let's get started with understanding the
loop statements in Java so first of all
understand why do we need Loop
statements so generally whenever you are
dealing with some data structures in
Java which can store multiple elements
for example we saw array which can store
multiple elements string is also
basically technically a character array
which is storing multiple character
factors so whenever you have these kind
of data structures where you have
multiple elements being stored in the
same then in that case you would like to
have a way to iterate or access all of
the elements in a seamless fashion one
of the ways is to access them
individually one by one but that's too
much of work that's too much of code
there has to be a simpler way of
accessing all the elements one by one if
I want to and that's where the majority
of the use cases for using Loops coming
to picture now Java provides multiple
constructs to write Loops in Java there
is a while loop there is a do while loop
there is a for Loop there is also an
enhanced for Loop and in the previous
versions of java a use case of iterator
was also very popular so there are
multiple ways in which you can actually
iterate over a collection and access all
the elements of the collection one by
one and you can use it to multiple
useful cases for example if you have a
huge eye of employee salary and you want
to give bonus to each of the employees
and add the bonus to the salary then you
need to do this addition for all the
employees it would be nice to have to
return a while loop and the while loop
can automatically access all the
employee salary one by one and keep
adding the bonus to the salary this
would be an easier way to do this rather
than individually updating each
employee's salary and the first Loop
statement we are going to understand is
a while loop so the syntax of while loop
is very straightforward you write the
while keyword you enter the actual
condition which will be evaluating to a
Boolean true or false so you write the
expression which will be a Boolean
expression exactly similar to the
conditions which you use to write in
your if statements so you write your
condition which will evaluate to either
true or false and then you write your
statement and these statements will keep
executing till the time this particular
expression evaluates to true so
generally the way it works is that it
will enter the while block it will
evaluate the expression if the
expression becomes true then the
statements inside this particular while
block will be executed and after the
execution of the statement it will again
go back again evaluate the expression we
call the steps basically so it will go
to the next step again evaluate the
expression if this again if this still
holds true it will again go inside
execute the statement move on to the
next step it will again go to the
evaluation so this this Loop will
continue to go till the time this
condition will hold true if it still
doesn't make sense for you don't worry
we will have a demo of it to make you
understand how to use the while loops
and maybe it's a good idea to switch to
the IDE and look at an example of it so
I have already created while demo for it
here it is it looks very small and
simple but it will get to the point
where we can understand how and why will
we will will be using the while Loops so
I've created a while demo class I have
added a public static void main method
here which is the entry point I have
declared a variable which is int count
equal to 1 so the count value is 1 right
now and then I'm writing a condition
here I'm saying while count is less than
10 do this so it will print the current
value of count and after that I'm using
the post increment unary operator if you
remember we covered this in the previous
sessions what is the meaning of this it
basically will increment the value of
count by one this expression is is
equivalent to if I write it in this way
if I write count equal to count plus one
this is exactly the same as this no
difference so this will have the same
impact I will just remove this line
because we already have the count plus
plus here so if we try to understand
this we are basically incrementing the
count and then checking the condition
again so at first time it will be 1 less
than 10 yes that is true it will go
inside and print the count value the
current count value which will be 1 and
then it does count plus plus so now the
count value becomes 2. it will again go
back here again check the condition
saying is 2 less than 10 yes that is
true so the while condition again
becomes true it will again go inside
this print the current value of count
which is 2 then do count plus plus so it
will again increment the value of count
so the now the count value becomes 3
again go back here at condition and
saying is 3 less than 10 yes that is
still true again come here print the
three again go here make count as four
four less than 10 prints four again
count plus plus count becomes 5 and so
on so forth it will keep doing that till
the value becomes 10 so at a step when
count plus plus results in the count
value being updated to 10 it will go
here and say is 10 less than 10 now that
is not true because 10 is equal to 10
but 10 is not less than 10 so this
condition will become false and it will
exit of this while loop and it will come
here and it will execute if there's if
there was anything written after the
while loop that will be executed so
that's the idea that you want to do
something till a particular condition
holds true then you can use the while
loop Define your condition and execute
the statements and try to do something
which changes the state of this
condition here I am changing the count
so that every time a new evaluation
happens if I comment this this will
result in an infinite Loop because one
will always be less than 10 I will not
be incrementing the count here and it
will keep running forever it will never
stop it will just keep printing one one
every time till your computer program
runs out of the memory so always
remember not to end up into an infinite
Loop that's probably one of the biggest
mistakes any beginner programmer does so
please try to be aware of that
particular loophole not try to run an
infinite Loop always try to write
something in the code block which can
change the state of the condition and
also make sure that that state condition
sometimes sometimes should become false
you should also make sure that that all
that always becomes false because if I
do this if I do this then this condition
will always remain true because it is
already 1 then it will become 0 then it
will become minus 1 minus 2 minus 3 so
and so forth but that value of count
will forever be less than 10 and again
you will never be able to exit this Loop
your program will be stuck in this Loop
till your program runs out of the memory
so always remember to write a statement
or a statement of execution in your in
your code block which can change the
state of the condition which results in
some eventual time when this condition
becomes false this condition has to
become false eventually otherwise you
will never come out of the loop always
remember that so if we run this program
now let's observe the output so we can
see here this particular statement is
printed for one two three four five six
seven eight nine and that's it after
nine the moment the count plus plus
resulted into the count value becoming
ten it checked that condition and then
it just came out of the loop because 10
is not less than 10 and the condition
became false so always do something
inside your code block which results at
least of one scenario where this
condition becomes false and that is how
you can use the while loop now you can
see this is a pretty generic code and
you can write any kind of condition here
write any a code you want to execute
here and then do something to change the
state of the condition as well in a
positive way in a way which results this
particular condition to be false at some
point of time and then your while loop
will run fine so this is all I wanted to
cover in terms of the while loop we have
lot of more exciting stuff coming in in
terms of different loops and in the next
session we are going to understand how a
do while loop Works let's get started
with four Loops in Java so so far we
covered about while loops and do while
loops and we also saw different examples
of using different types of data
structures like arrays but one of the
core requirements whenever you are
working with any kind of collection is
to iterate over it exactly similar to
what I explained in the do while and why
lectures that you would often require to
iterate over a collection or a data
structure and for that one of the most
sophisticated and easiest way to do that
is using for loops so let's understand
the syntax of for Loop first and then we
will also look at an example of it in
the in the Eclipse IDE so I have just
opened the official Java docs here so if
you see this is basically the syntax of
a for Loop statement so let's understand
it and let's also try to compare it with
a while loop so that we can understand
how it Compares with the while loop so
if we see the syntax we first see the
term initialization then we see the term
termination and then we see the term
called increment now if I try to compare
it with a while loop there also you
basically did these three things you
first initialized a variable outside the
while loop which is called
initialization and then you wrote a
condition which is your termination
condition you wrote a condition saying
let's say while I is greater than 10 or
while I is less than 10 so that is the
condition which is also the termination
statement the loop will continue to
execute till that condition evaluates to
false and that's when the loop
terminates that's why we call it as
termination and then the third piece of
it is the increment the I plus plus
which we used to do in the while Loops
so these three portions together make or
constitute any kind of loop in any kind
of programming language and for Loop if
you see the the kind of code which you
use to write in a while loop in multiple
lines where you first initialize a
variable then you write a condition in
the while block and then inside the
while block you use to increment the
variable all of that can be done in a
single line in the for Loop and that's
why I said it is the most sophisticated
and easiest way to write Loops in Java
so you write all of these three things
the initialization the condition and the
increment or decrement values in the
single line and then use start with the
curly braces and you write the code
which you want to keep executing till
the condition evaluates to false that's
the basic syntax of it so let us try to
understand this with the help of an
example so here I have opened a class
which is called for demo and this is a
class which will demonstrate the usage
of a for Loop so again we have a public
static voidbane method which you can see
here which is the entry point and then I
use the keyword for I put standard
braces for the brackets and then I do
the initialization so this part is the
initialization part you initialize the
variable so I just say in time equal to
1 initialization done you end it with a
semicolon so that it is a single
statement understood by Java and then
you write this condition which is your
evaluation slash termination condition
so this condition is basically the the
deciding factor of how long your Loop
should run it's exactly similar to what
you used to write in the while blog if I
just show you the example this is what
we used to do so we did the
initialization at line number seven then
we wrote this termination condition
inside the while syntax or the construct
and then we did the increment here so we
are doing all of these three steps but
we are doing it in a single line so this
is the condition and then we write our
increment or decrement values which are
going to change the evaluation condition
every time at every step so we are
saying I plus plus so technically what I
am saying here is that start with i
equal to 1 and then check the condition
I less than 10 so the in the in the
first step it will be checking if 1 is
less than 10 if the condition holds true
go inside the for Loop execute the
statement at line number seven and then
go back to this particular statement so
we do y plus plus so I becomes 2 and
then you again go back to the condition
and again you check if 2 is is less than
10 yes it is so again you go inside
inside the for Loop and do whatever is
written there there can be multiple
statements here for now I have just
written one system dot out dot println
so that happens and once all the
execution is finished inside the block
it will again go back to the increment
that's the increment so 2 plus 1 becomes
3 again does the evaluation exec and if
the if the condition holds true it will
again go inside so this will continue
this condition checking execution and
increment will continue till the time
this condition holds true the moment
this condition becomes false the control
will come out at line number nine so
that's the basic anatomy and control
flow it's very important to understand
the control flow of a for Loop otherwise
you might end up into a program which is
forever running and which will just heat
up all the memory available in your jvm
so be very sure of what you write in
your for Loop be very sure of especially
these two parts the condition and the
increment or decrement so this is very
important piece the initialization
happens only once and then this
condition evaluates if the condition
holds to True some code executes goes
back to the changing statement which can
be an increment to decrement whatever
and again compares the updated value
with the condition so this will keep
happening let's run this code to
interpret the output
so I will right click go to run as Java
application and if I interpret the
output here I can see that it started
with count is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 and 9. it
stopped at nine so what happened there
let's try to evaluate the termination
condition so let's say I has become 9
and 9 is less than 10 so it goes inside
and it prints count is 9 which is I then
it goes here and it says 9 plus 1 I plus
plus means nine plus one the current
value of I plus 1 it becomes ten and
then it again compares the condition so
now 10 is not less than 10 10 is equal
to 10 but it is not less than 10. so the
condition becomes false and count is 10
is never printed because this condition
has become false it will jump out so
let's say if I do this if I put an equal
to here and if I now execute the same
program
this time I will see 10 here and because
I have said that okay check the
condition if 10 is less than equal to 10
that will become true it will print
count is 10 then it will increment and
the count will become 11 the I will
become 11 and then it will check 11 is
less than equal to 10 no it is not so
condition becomes false and the control
comes out of the loop so that's how you
should always try to interpret the loops
you can also run some infinite Loops for
example if I say I equal to 1 I leave it
that and I say I minus minus so what
happens I equal to 1 1 is less than 10
yes it goes here prints the value and
then I decrement the value I don't
increment the value I decrement the
value so whatever value comes out will
always be less than 10 and this Loop
will run forever for fun let's try to
run this and I will I will have to kill
this program manually but just to show
you what happens and what you should not
do in your in your Java program so you
see it will continuously keep printing
the values till the program runs out of
memory till it eats up all the available
memory it is cut it is forever running
it will never stop because the condition
will never remain never never evaluate
to false this condition will forever be
true so the loop will run forever so I'm
just gonna kill the program but this is
something which you should avoid
whenever you are writing Java code and
this happens quite often with beginner
programmers so this is all I wanted to
cover in today's session we talked in
detail about the for Loop and in the
next session we are going to talk about
another interesting way of writing for
Loops which is also called enhanced for
Loops let's get started with enhanced
for Loops in Java so we covered about
the for loops and the structure of it
and the control flow of it in the
previous session and today we are just
going to talk about another way of
writing for Loops which is a bit even
more smarter than the traditional for
Loops which we call as enhanced for
Loops we generally use the enhanced form
Loops for scenarios whenever we have to
iterate over a collection of items or an
array of items those are the most
popular and common use cases of using
enhanced for Loop and this for Loop is
even simpler like I said it's even
simpler than writing a classic for Loop
and the syntax is simply like this you
again start with for put the standard
brackets and then let's start from the
right most because then I will be able
to explain it better you specify the
collection in the right most side of the
bracket The Collection can be an array
it can be a list it can be a map so
whatever different kind of collections
which are available in Java and we are
going to cover collections in detail so
don't worry if you don't understand what
are lists and what are maps and what are
sets we will go into detail of each of
these one by one in the upcoming
sessions but the idea is that you put
the collection to the right most then
you put a colon and then you put a
presentation of the member of this
collection so for example here this
numbers is basically an INT array so
this int array means that this array Can
Only Hold integer numbers and that's why
we write int here because this array is
only having integers then we put any
placeholder variable name this can be
anything you can even write it as I if
you want to you can write it as anything
any variable name which you want to
write this is a temporary variable so
now this code is going to execute in a
manner that it is going to iterate over
this array one by one starting from the
first element going till the last
element you don't need to write any
initialization code you don't need to
write any termination condition code and
you don't need to write any increment or
decrement code also and how these threes
how these three values are actually
taken here of let's understand that as
well so when we talk about the
initialization as I have put an array
here a data structure here the automatic
initialization index is going to be the
first index so when we do the iteration
when this for Loop is going to execute
it is automatically going to initialize
a temporary variable with the value at
the first index which is the index 0 as
you know that array is a zero index
based structure then comes the condition
part so the condition evaluation is
going to be again based on the size of
the array or the size of the data
structure which you are using it is
going to start from the first index
which is the index 0 and it is going to
iterate till the arrays last element is
reached so technically start from the
index 0 and go till the last element
that's your evaluation condition and
then comes the increment part so at each
step after it has successfully accessed
the first element automatically the
index is going to be updated to pointing
to the next element so if it starts from
here once the first step iteration is
complete I is automatically going to be
incremented to index 1 and then it will
basically this I will be holding 2 then
in the next iteration the same I is
going to be holding 3. similarly I will
keep holding the new value of the
collection item one by one till the
collection items last element is reached
so this is the basic premise that you
can write a collection variable here and
keep iterating over it and this whatever
variable you write here will hold the
current items value one by one so in the
first step this I is going to hold 1 in
the Second Step this I is going to hold
2 in the the third step this eye is
going to hold 3 and so on so forth
that's the basic idea so now let's run
this program to see what kind of output
do we get so you can see we basically
are able to print all the elements of
the array and that's probably one of the
most popular usage as well that if you
want to just print all the elements or
access all the elements of array or a
collection one by one then just use
enhance for Loop so you can see at each
step it is printing the value of I and
the value of I is basically the
subsequent elements of the array that's
the whole idea with enhanced for Loop
under the hoods if you talk about how
does it work under the hood it is
actually using the classic for Loop
construct itself but for developers it
is making it easier because it knows
that if you are iterating over a
collection you will start with the first
element and you will go till the last
element so it knows the initialization
value the termination condition and it
also knows the increment condition and
that's the reason you will use enhanced
for Loops in Java for iterating over
Collections and in the next session we
will be talking about the nested for
Loops concept and we will be looking at
an example of how to implement nested
for loops and when do we use nested for
Loops let's get started with nested for
Loops in Java so we talked about the
while Loops the do while Loops the
classic for Loop also the enhanced for
Loop so now we are going to look at a
variation of the classic for Loops in a
in a condition where we have to use more
than one Loop in a nested fashion and
how do we do that what are the use cases
when we use that so in front of you you
can see an example which I have prepared
for nested for loops and in this
particular example I have created a
two-dimensional array as you can see on
the line number six I have created an
integer array and I have put two square
brackets here which are basically really
symbolizing that this is a two
dimensional array so this two
dimensional array is going to hold
technically a 2d Matrix and we are going
to use the concept of nested for Loops
to print this 2D array in a 2d Matrix
style where you will be able to see the
rows and columns clearly let's first try
to interpret this particular 2D array so
we have a curly braces outside and then
we have these three Inner Elements which
symbolizes three rows basically so this
is the first row this is the second row
and this is the third row and then each
of the rows have three elements each
which symbolizes the column values or
the item values so it's basically a 3
into 3 2D array which has three rows and
three columns so so we can say that this
is basically a 3 into 3 array which has
three dimensions on the row side and
three dimensions on the column side or
just a three by three Matrix or three by
three 2D array so as we know that in
case of arrays everything starts from 0
so technically if we talk about the
indexes it would be the index 0 index 1
and index 2 on the row side and
similarly index 0 index 1 and index 2 on
the column side so that's that's
something which you should remember
because that we are going to use this
particular concept when we write the for
Loop so let's try to write the for Loop
now if you look at line number eight we
put this keyword called for and then we
write the initialization so we say int I
equal to 0 then we are writing the
termination condition and we are saying
run this particular Loop run this whole
Loop which ends at line 13 till I is
less than 3 and keep incrementing I at
every step that's what I'm doing in the
line number eight then inside the for
loop I am writing another for Loop which
has another different variable called J
it can be anything you can name it
anything you want and this also starts
with 0 and this also has a similar
condition which is which says run this
particular Loop the line 10 basically or
this Loop which is signified by this
curly brushes run this particular Loop
till the time the value of J is less
than 3 and keep incrementing J at every
step and at line number 10 print the
element of array which has the current
value of I and the current value of J
these are basically the positions these
are not the elements the element would
be represented by this whole but print
the element which is at current I and
J's position values that's what this
code means so let's try to do a dry run
on this particular code to understand
how this is going to work so at first we
have I equal to 0 0 is less than 3 and
it goes in inside it initializes J as
well with 0 and J is 0 is also Less Than
3 so this condition went true that's why
we went to line number nine and line
number nine condition also went to true
so we went to line number 10. remember
that in this particular case at line
number 10 the values of I and J are 0
and 0 respectively and we are saying
print the array of 0 and 0 so 0th rows
0th column element should be printed so
this is the 0th row because this is the
first uh first sub log and this is the
first element so in this case in line
number 10 2 should get printed then it
goes here and it increments the J to 1
so 0 plus 1 becomes one it again checks
the condition is 1 Less Than 3 so yes 1
is less than 3 it goes here remember it
did not go up at line number eight it
just came back from line number nine so
when it comes here I is still 0 0 but J
has moved from 0 to 1 so now we are
trying to access the element which is at
zeroth row First Column which is going
to be 7 so 7 is going to get printed
similarly on the next iteration J is
going to get incremented from 1 to 2 and
again the condition will be evaluated so
2 is less than 3 all good it will again
come back to line number 10 and now it
will say print the value of 0 Row third
or the second column or the third
element so zeroth Row Third element
which is the 9 so 9 will get printed
then again J will be incremented and J
will become 3 2 plus 1 3 and now the
condition will be evaluated is 3 Less
Than 3 no it is not less than 3 the
condition becomes false so it breaks out
of the loop goes to line number 12
prints an empty line because we are not
writing anything here so it will just
print a blank line and now it will go
back to line number AIDS condition and
it will do an increment of I and now I
will move from 0 to 1 and now the
evaluation will happen is 1 Less Than 3
yes 1 is less than 3 so it will again go
to line number nine again initialize J
with a fresh zero the previous J got
destroyed the moment you came out of the
loop so this is a new J so this J again
gets initialized to 0 0 is less than 3
it goes here remember I was 1 in this
time so now it will print the value of
this 2D array which is sitting at 1
comma 0 basically second row first
element so second row first element
which is three again J is going going to
get incremented and it will become from
0 to 1 so 1 is less than 3 yes it will
again come here and it will print the
value of the array which is sitting at
array of 1 comma 1. for a row equal to 1
and column equal to 1 which will be 6
Sim similarly J will get incremented
again again 2 is less than 3 come back
here we'll print 1 then again we'll
increment J J will become 3 3 is less
than 3 no it's false the condition is
false so it jumps out of the loop goes
to line number 12 prints a blank line
again goes back to 8 line number eight
increments I and I now becomes 2 2 is
less than 3 yes it will again go here
initialize J again with 0 and again does
the same thing for the Row 2 and column
0 1 2 and again it will come out of the
loop this time again when it will go
here the value will become from 2 to 3
and 3 is not less than 3 so then it will
break out of the outer loop so the idea
is execute the inner loop for every
value of the outer loop remember this
line because that is how you will be
applying your knowledge of nested for
Loops to be used in certain condition so
whenever you have a scenario where you
have to iterate over a collection based
on a certain value of another collection
then you can use nested for Loops or you
have a scenario where you have to
iterate over 2D or 3D arrays for example
if we were dealing with 3D arrays then
you would have seen three nested for
Loops here and where it will apply the
same logic that iterate over all the
collections all the values of the inner
loop on a particular value of the outer
loop then increment the value of the
outer loop and do the same thing again
iterate over all the values of the inner
loop based on a fixed value of the outer
loop so let's run this program and let's
see what kind of output do we get so
like I said our our motive our Target
was to print this in a matrix style and
you can see that it is printing in it in
a sort of a matrix representation so the
first row gets printed here then the
second row gets printed here and then
the third row gets printed here if you
try to decipher it it will work exactly
the same way as I explained so I equal
to 0 0 Less Than 3 condition becomes
true comes here J equal to 0 J Less Than
3 condition becomes true comes here
prints the array of zero comma 0 which
is 2 then prints the array of zero comma
1 which is 7 0 comma 2 which is 9 then J
becomes 3 it breaks out of the loop goes
up here I becomes from 0 to 1 1 is less
than 3 Yes again comes here re
initializes a fresh for loop with a new
J setting to zero and it will go it will
print the array of 1 0 1 1 1 2 then
similarly array of two zero two one two
two so that's basically what we are
doing we are iterating we are picking
the first row and iterating all elements
of it picking the second row iterating
all all elements over it and so on so
forth you can do this for any n
dimensional kind of array or a
collection so this is all I wanted to
cover in today's session where we
discussed about the nested for Loops
concept and how and where we will use it
and in the next session we will be
discussing about the Java Collections
framework let's get started with
collections in Java or the collections
framework in Java I must say that this
is probably the most important concept
of the Java programming language which
you will be using heavily whenever you
are working in any production grade
application so let's understand the
collections framework and the different
classes and the utilities available
inside the collections framework this is
going to be a theoretical lecture
because there is a lot of ground to
cover in this lecture so we will only
focus on understanding the relationship
between the classes why those classes
are created because each class has a
different purpose in this framework and
we will obviously talk about the
hierarchy as well in the upcoming
sessions we will go into the Hands-On
exercise of some of the most popular
collections we will not be able to
provide Hands-On of all the collections
classes which you which you can see on
the screen because then it is going to
take a very very long time to complete
this concept but we will cover the most
popular ones or the most used ones out
of this particular framework so let's
get started as you can see there let's
first understand some of the symbols
here and let me just zoom this in a bit
so that it's visible yep now though I
have just increased the resolution a bit
so you can see there are three different
symbols or Legends here you see this
oval shape which is called interface so
you can see some interfaces here then
you see this uh rectangular blue box
which is called abstract class and you
can see some these blue boxes and then
you see the purple box which is called
the class and you see some classes here
these ones so for now we are currently
we haven't covered the concept of
interfaces and Abstract classes but we
will cover that in the coming lectures
and for understanding the collections
hierarchy right now the at least the
concepts of it you don't need to be
fully aware of the concept of interfaces
or abstract classes so let's dive deeper
into the framework eye table is
basically an interface uh to to give you
a very simple definition of an interface
interface basically is sort of a
declaration which will tell you what
kind of classes will be present under
the interface for example if you have
two let's just store all the cars and
all the bikes and all the bicycles and
all the trucks from all around the world
then you can create an interface called
vehicle and create all of these classes
under the interface and these classes
will be about cars about trucks and
about other kind of vehicles so an
interface is a generic blueprint of
specific class implementation that's a
very simple definition of an interface
and like I said we will go deeper into
this concept in the upcoming lectures so
that was about interfaces similarly when
we talk about abstract classes the next
Legend here abstract classes are also
similar to interfaces where they provide
you a generalization but at the same
time abstract classes provide you a way
to also write some concrete
implementation for example if we take
the example of a bank account so there
in a bank you have different kinds of
accounts you have savings account you
have recurring accounts you have current
accounts and there are many other
different types of accounts so there
would be some common implementation and
logic which will be applicable to all
the account types for example an account
must have an account holder that account
holder must have a valid kyc done for
example well so there would be some sort
of common logic which will be applicable
to all of these right so that common
logic so you have two options either you
can write that common logic again and
again in the savings account class in
the current account class in the loan
account class etc etc or you can write
it at a central place and just refer it
from there so that's where you will you
will use abstract classes so you will
create an abstract class of an account
and then you will create these child
classes under this account class which
will be the savings account class The
Loan account class the current account
class Etc so this is a very lightening
introduction to you about interfaces and
Abstract classes and class as we know is
basically a concrete blueprint which
holds data and logic together so here I
treble is an interface which will just
specify that all the kinds of data
structure which can be iterated which
can be looped over should be present
under this particular interface that's
why we created this interface so under
eye table we have this collections
interface and this will govern that
everything which will present under the
collection interface will be holding
some sort of a collection of items now
we look at the next set of interfaces we
see a set interface we see a list
interface and we see a queue interface
when we talk about the set interface
these three different types of
interfaces represent three different
properties of collection and these
properties are exclusive of each other
for example if we talk about set so set
has a property that everything which you
put into set will be unique it will
never ever tolerate or contain any
duplicate elements that's the property
offset so now you can see whenever you
have a scenario where there is a strict
constraint that your collection should
never have duplicates you will use sets
when we talk about lists list is
probably the most lenient representation
of a collection it can store anything it
can store duplicates as well it will not
raise an error or a warning if you store
same element multiple times it will
happily store it but at the same time
the list is basically an index based
collection you can access the elements
starting from the index 0 till the last
element that's the basic value
proposition so whenever you have a
requirement where you want to access the
elements into a predefined sequence and
one by one then you should use list also
the order is fixed here the first
element will always come after the
zeroth element the second element will
always come after the first element so
whenever you iterate over this
particular list you will never have a
scenario where you do not know the order
of the elements being accessed they will
always be accessed in a predefined order
so it's basically we can call it as an
indexed ordered collection which can
hold applicates then the third one is Q
here so Q is basically as you can this
is basically inspired from Real World so
think of any queue if you if you go to
buy something at a grocery store or if
you go to buy a ticket at a railway
station or you go to the check-in
counter at the airports so you stand in
a queue and the concept of queue is that
it works on a concept of first in first
out the person who first went into the
queue will be the person first being
served and coming out of the queue and
if the second person come that has to be
standing behind the first person and
once the first person is served and goes
out of the queue the second person comes
at the front of the queue and that that
particular person is served so you can
see it's the if you have to store that
kind of behavior or if you have to
implement that kind of behavior in a
Java program then you would use queues
so so this was about the top top level
interfaces which are set list and queue
and out of these list and set are very
very popularly used very heavily used in
any kind of java Enterprise grade
application now there are more
interfaces like sorted set navigable set
and DQ sorted set is basically forcing
additional constraint on the set that
the elements will be unique at the same
time you can also have the elements into
a sorted order that sorting can be an
incremental sorting or decremental
sorting that depends but the whole idea
is that it will be sorted similarly
navigable set brings another navigation
kind of properties DQ is basically a
double ended queue where the elements
can be inserted and removed both from
the front and from the back so there are
the different properties of these
interfaces but like I said the most
popular ones are these three ones now
let's talk about the abstract classes so
the abstract classes you see here here
are abstract collection abstract set
abstract list abstract queue abstract
sequential list generally you will not
be using these directly you don't need
to use them directly but you should be
aware that they exist if you have a very
specific case where you want to use
these abstract classes you can use them
in Java program but most of the time you
don't need to use them and most of the
times you will be dealing with either
the interfaces or you will be dealing
with the concrete classes now this
lecture is is getting a bit long so I
will like to stop this lecture here so
we covered about the interfaces part of
the collection and we also understood a
bit about the abstract classes though we
are not going to use abstract classes in
much detail in the programs in the next
session we will cover the second part of
this collection framework or the
remaining part of this collections
framework which is around the classes
let's get started with discussing the
concrete classes in the collections
framework in the previous session we
talked about the interfaces part of it
where we discussed about sets the lists
and the queues and we also touched a bit
upon the abstract classes and like I
mentioned earlier you don't need to
generally use these abstract classes
directly in your Java program but you
must be aware that they exist you see
some arrows here right if you see if I
just scroll up you see multiple kind of
arrows here these arrows mean that if
the arrow goes from bottom to top it
means this particular element is a type
of the parent it's basically a denoting
a parent child kind of relationship so
for example here you see preset is
basically a navigable set and also
extend extends abstract set which
extends set so similarly you can see all
kind of complex relationships here and
generally you don't need to remember all
of of those you only need to remember
the few and those few are basically
easily can be spotted for example
whenever you see a tree set it means
it's basically a type of set whenever
you see a word called list that means
that it is a type of list and you all
whenever you see a word called Q then it
means that it is a type of queue so
let's understand these classes let's
first go to the list interface so you
can see list interface has the
relationship with abstract list and from
there it goes down to error list
abstract list has another child which is
called abstract sequential list which is
another abstract class and which has a
concrete class which is called linked
list so let's understand these two
collections or these two uh types of
lists right now so when we talk about
arraylist let's understand this we
already have covered arrays so what are
arraylists they are very similar to
arrays in in a way that they are also
indexed based collections so you can
store elements and access them based on
the index position starting from 0 going
till the length minus 1 index and this
is an ordered collection you can access
the elements only in a predefined
sequence it can obviously accept
duplicates as well and these all are
properties are also applicable to arrays
the differentiating factor here is that
arraylist is a dynamic array it's not a
static array if you remember when we
talked about arrays we had to initialize
it or we had to specify a fixed size of
it while we initialize it once you have
initialized the array size you cannot
change the array size it is static it is
fixed so if you have created an array of
elements 10 and if you are trying to
store the 11th element you are going to
get an array of array index bound of
exception but in case of array List It
dynamically updates its size based on
the number of elements stored you can
still initialize it with some some
initial size let's say you initialize an
error list and you say that you want to
initialize it with the size of 10
elements absolutely fine but the moment
you Str you try to store the 11th
element array list is going to
dynamically update its size from 10 to
something else so it will keep updating
its size based on the number of number
of elements which are coming to the
collection that's the whole property of
arraylist so remember it's it's used in
the cases when you have an ordered
collection to store and you want to
access them based on the index and you
want a dynamic update of the size the
second sibling of it which is linked
list is also a type of list but it has
slightly different properties than
arraylist in case of arraylist it was an
index based collection you access the
element based on the indexes but in
linked list you access the elements
based on the previous this and the next
element that's pretty much what it knows
so an item can only be accessed in a
particular sequence starting from head
to the tail and when we talk about
linked list the idea is that you have an
element which will have a data and it
will also have a pointer or a basically
a reference that reference will be
pointing to the next element in the
linked list similarly the next element
will store the value the actual data and
it will also store a reference to the
next element so you can see if you have
to go to The Fifth Element you cannot
directly say link list of five the way
you can say this in arraylist because
arraylist is an index based position
list right so you can access the zeroth
element or the fifth element or the
tenth element directly just in one line
or one go but in case of linked list you
cannot access the fifth element or the
last element of the linked list directly
you have to start from the first element
and keep jumping the reference is till
you reach the last element that's the
property of linked list so these are the
two types of list now let's talk about
the type of set a type of set which is
not mentioned here is Hash set which is
a very popular type so a set generally
has two popular types hash set and
preset so let's talk about both of those
if I talk about hash set the property is
that it will inherit the existing
properties of set which is that element
should be unique that's good but along
with that hash set will not remember or
honor the order in which the elements
are inserted into it it will if let's
say if you insert 15 or 20 different
elements inside hash set and then if you
try to iterate over the hash set every
time the order in which the elements are
accessed and printed will be different
every time the order of accession will
be different every time the act the way
in which the elements are accessed their
order will be different you cannot
predict that and that's the property of
hash set whereas when we talk about
reset in case of preset you can have a
sort of fixed order and a tree hierarchy
so a tree hierarchy if you know about
the tree data structure from the data
structure and algorithm section you
already would know what a tree looks
like basically it has a root and it has
child this is basically you can call
this artery as well right so whenever
you have to store the values in a in a
tree fashion where you can navigate
through the parent and Childs then you
would use the preset and remember since
it is a set it will still inherit the
uniqueness property of set so that's
about hash set and preset so we covered
about list we covered about sets now
let's talk about these ones which are
vector stack and priority queue so let's
first understand about priority queue so
you would use a priority queue when you
need a fee for arrangement but at the
same time if there are few elements in
the queue which cannot wait to be
executed or processed when their turn
comes they want it to be executed on
priority so whenever you have such use
case where you want to to maintain a
fifo fashion collection but at the same
time you also want to allow few elements
of it to override this fee for
arrangement and get processed ahead of
their queue number so you can use
priority queue in those cases talking
about stack let's understand stack first
and stack is a lifo Arrangement last in
first out so remember in your house when
you when you put plates or the the
normal dinner plates over one one over
each other you are basically creating a
stack so the property is that the plate
which is put first on the table will be
picked up at the very last and the plate
which is put the last on the stack let's
say you put five plates on top of one uh
one on top of other then the fifth plate
will be consumed first anybody would
pick the plate from the very top they
will not pick the bottom plate because
it's it's almost impossible if you have
a big stack you cannot pull out the
bottom most plate the stack will fall
down so you will always pick out the
elements from the top so it has a leaf
arrangement so whenever you have to
create a last in first out kind of
arrangement in your program for storing
collections you will use stack talking
about vectors vectors are very similar
to lists they are exactly similar there
is basically one major difference is
that vectors are thread safe and lists
are not thread safe Now list has
provided a way to be thread safe we will
cover that later but for now you can
understand that whenever you have a
program in which you want to access a
collection in a thread safe manner where
two threads cannot modify the same
element at the same time then then you
will use vectors so we covered about the
complete collections framework classes
the interfaces and the abstract classes
and always remember the the reason why
you will use arraylist or linked list or
a hash set or a preset or a vector or a
priority queue or a stack that is the
most important concept I want you to
take away from this session let's get
started with arraylists in Java so when
we talk about error list we are
technically talking about a list in the
previous session I covered in detail
about the various implementation of list
interface which were analyst and linked
list and in today's session we'll be
focusing only on the arraylist I have
opened the API documentation of the
arraylist class so if we just scroll
down we will see a nice description
which is provided by Java and it broadly
covers all the points which I described
in the previous session which were that
an error list is basically an array
based implementation of a list it's an
indexed based implementation so you can
access the elements based on their index
position you can directly access any
element if you know its index it accepts
any kind of duplicates as well and by
default it is not thread safe if two
threads are trying to access the same
collection at the same time or maybe
trying to modify the collection then you
will get inconsistent Behavior so that
was about the basic description of
arraylist there are it provides lot of
interesting utility methods as well for
adding elements for adding multiple
elements for removing elements for
fetching an element from the error list
and we will cover those methods in
detail in the demo and with that maybe
let's switch to the demo so for this I
have created a class which is called
arraylist demo it has a public static
void main method and it has an arraylist
example written inside it so at line
number 10 you see that there is an
initialization happening for the error
list and this is how you basically
initialize the arraylist to start with
you write the interface name so you can
obviously write arraylist as well here
instead of list you can write arraylist
that is absolutely acceptable but the
reason I have written list here is
because it is a better practice or I
would say it is a best practice to
always initialize the concrete
implementations with the interface type
I'm making a very generic statement
which is applicable to collections and
at any other type of classes and objects
you might be creating in your program
always try to declare it with the type
of interface and then Define the
concrete implementation on the right
hand side so the LHS or the left hand
side will contain the interface
declaration and the right hand side will
contain the concrete implementation the
reason for this is that if tomorrow if
you have to change the representation of
this arraylist to let's say a linked
list then you don't need to do a lot of
work because the linked list is also a
child of the list interface so since
list understands and knows about both of
the classes you can interchangeably use
this reference to point to any of those
implementations that's why it is
considered a best practice to basically
write the left hand side as the
interface and the right hand side as the
concrete implementation that's the first
bit of it second interesting thing you
notice is this so you see these
Expressions here and this basically
encloses any kind of generics or Class
Type what are generics we will cover
this in detail in the upcoming sessions
for now what you can understand and what
you should know that these are denoting
a class type of which the objects will
be stored inside this particular list so
once I say list of integer it means that
this particular list is only going to
hold integer objects if you try to
insert a string object or if you try to
insert a character object or if you try
to insert a float object or any other
kind of object it will create an error
because it remember in the very first
lecture we said that Java is strongly
typed language it has very strong checks
for these kind of data type mismatch so
if that's why it will expect you to
specify the object type here and
whatever type you have specified here
that's the kind of objects which are
going to be stored inside this list I
have been using these terms called
classes and objects into interchangeably
but for now what you can understand that
this is a type how how we write classes
and how we write objects and how we
create objects again I will cover this
in detail in the upcoming sessions so we
have specified the list interface and
I'm saying that this particular variable
should hold any list of integer type
then on the right hand side I am
specifying what type of list this error
list is and this error list will be an
arraylist Class Type and again I have to
specify the Class Type
specifications and then I'm specifying a
size here this is the size of the error
list the initial size of the error list
you can obviously write it without this
as well this is also a perfectly fine
statement in Java and in this case the
array list is going to be initialized
with its default size if you specify a
value then the error list will be
initialized with only that size it is
also considered a best practice to
always initialize the error list with
some known initial value let's say if
this error list is going to store only
two elements and the default size is
definitely way way bigger than two
elements then you are going to waste lot
of memories so that's why it is a best
practice to specify explicitly specify
some sort of an initial size this is
also acceptable because it is
automatically inferring the type from
the Declaration you don't need to
specify it again here in fact some of
this modern Ides will also show you a
warning if you write it here so the next
thing I'm going to do is basically going
to add some elements to this error list
so I've created an error list which
should hold only integer values and it
should hold to start with five values
but it will not complain if you try to
add the sixth value so for that I have
just written a small Loop here let me
just put curly braces around it for
readability so I am saying in time equal
to 1 I should be less than equal to 5 I
plus plus and I keep doing arraylist Dot
add so this add method is the method
which is used to add elements to the
array list so whenever you have to add
an element to the error list remember
you need to use the method add and then
specify the actual element which is
supposed to be added so I'm adding one
two three four five in this error list
one by one using this Loop and then I am
just printing the whole arraylist that's
what I'm doing here after that to
showcase is another operation of this
arraylist I am removing an element and
if we have to remove an element from
error list just simply called errorlist
dot remove and specify the index from
which you want to remove the element
remember you need to specify the index
and as I said in the beginning this is
an array based implementation so this is
going to start from 0. so when I say
remove the element at index 3
technically it's the fourth element of
the error list after that once we have
removed the element I am again
displaying the modify dial list and then
printing all the elements of the error
list one by one and for for fetching the
element if you see here if you if you
observe this particular for loop I am
using couple of more interesting methods
of the arraylist let's understand those
methods as well and then I will run the
program so here you see that I'm saying
int I equal to 0 and then I am saying I
less than error list dot size so in if
this error list has a capacity initial
capacity of storing five elements and
I've just added five elements to it then
the error list dot size will be 5 but it
says less than so it will start from 0
and run till I equal to 4 because the
moment I becomes 5 5 is not less than 5
and it will come out of the loop so
basically I'm trying to start this Loop
where I eyes value starts from 0 and
goes till 4 and here I am calling
another error list method which is used
to fetch an element from the error list
so whenever you have to get an element
from the error list just call Dot get on
the error list so arraylist dot get and
I'm specifying the I value so errorless
dot get of 0 get of 1 get of 2 get of
three and get a 4 and that's technically
the five elements which are stored in
this arraylist so let's run this program
so and now let's observe the outputs
here let me just bring the outputs down
yeah so at first I'm just printing the
error list so nothing nothing I'm just
adding the elements and printing the
complete error list so if you want to
just print the whole error list just put
that inside system dot out dot printable
and the whole error list will be printed
that's line 17 then I remove the element
at index 3. so if I Traverse through
this particular list this is index 0
index 1 index 2 and index 3. so index 3
has an element which has a value 4 and
I'm saying arraylist dot remove the
element at index 3. so this particular
element should be removed from this
particular list when I call the line 20
and then if I print the modified error
list at line 24 I can see that 4 is gone
now it's only one two three five that's
the remaining list you also need to
notice that whenever I call
system.out.println with error list I get
this square brackets which is the
representation of an arraylist if you
don't want that you might not want that
always right if you want to print this
nicely without the square brackets then
you have to iterate over the arraylist
and that's what I'm doing here I'm going
from 0 to errorless dot size and I'm
doing get of 0 get of 1 get of 2 and get
of three and that's how I get these
values without 4. we can also write the
same Loop using for enhanced Loop so
let's say if I write for INT I colon
array list and then inside it I can just
say system dot out dot print Ln I and if
I comment this particular Loop for for a
moment and run this program
I see the values one by one because it's
Ln so every output comes on on a new
line but you can pretty much see the
same output if I remove this and if I
write it like this just adding an extra
space it will look a bit more nice a bit
more formatted like this so as you can
see that we can get the pretty much the
same output either using a classic for
Loop style which is a bit verbose or you
can use an enhanced for Loop which is a
much simpler and shorter and less
verbose way of doing exactly the same
thing you don't even need to call the
errorless dot get I but I the reason I
put this example because I wanted to
show you the get functionality as well
so that's all we are going to talk about
in this session in the next session we
will be discussing about linked list
which is the another implementation of
the list interface let's get started
with linked lists in Java in the
previous session we talked about
arraylists and today we are going to
talk about the another type of
implementation of the list interface
which is called linked list if you
remember from the previous sessions we
discussed about the properties of the
linked list and all those properties are
listed here as well so basic idea is
that whenever you want to have a kind of
implementation where the order of the
elements is strictly maintained where
the first element can refer to the
second element the second element can
refer to the third element and so on in
those kind of cases you are going to use
linked list another property of linked
list is that you cannot randomly access
an element directly as you as you could
do in case of error list in case of
error list you just cite you just write
analyst dot get and you provide the
index location and you get the element
right away that's not possible in linked
list in linked list if you have to
access the let's say the second last
element or the fifth element in a 10
size element list in in that case you
have to start from the head which is the
first element and keep traversing Till
The Fifth Element that's the only way
possible to access the fifth element for
any random element so that's the
property of linked list it is also not
synchronized so if multiple threads are
trying to access a linked list
concurrently at least one of the threads
and and one of the threads tries to
modify the list then it must be
synchronized externally by some other
ways otherwise you will get
unpredictable results
and again this also provides a bunch of
utility methods and we will cover some
of those methods as you can see add
method for adding an element add all add
first contains get first get lost we
will cover some of these methods in the
demonstration which follows this
particular documentation and with that
let's jump to the implementation so I
have prepared an example here for the
linked list which is called linked list
demo I've just created a class for it
and we have created a public static void
main method here and here you can see at
line number 10 I have declared a linked
list so this looks very similar to the
way we declared an error list you see if
you have noticed on the LHS I have root
I have written the concrete class and I
have not written the interface reason
being I'm using some concrete methods
and actual methods which are only
available in the linked list class so I
am not looking at the reusability aspect
in this particular exam sample if you
are then you have to add extra code for
it but here I'm just writing linked list
and again in this particular linked list
I'm saying that I would only store
string objects so that's why inside
these braces I write string and then I
say new linked list string again I have
not specified the size so it will take
the default size as per the jvm
implementation now I have declared my
linked list and it's time to add some
elements to the linked list for that I
have the method add which is available
in this linked list class which will
provide me with the capability to add
elements so at line number 12 and line
number 13 I'm adding two elements and if
you remember I told you that it works in
a reference based implementation so at
first an element a will be added and
when you try to add element B element is
reference will be updated to point to B
that's what will happen in this linked
list and then at line 14 I am using
another interesting utility method of
this linked list class which says add
last what this method does that
specifically it will add the element at
the very end of the linked list so that
was about add last and if I talk about
line 15 I'm using another interesting
method of linked list class which is
called add first so what this will do
that this is going to insert this
element D at the very beginning of this
linked list like even before a d will be
inserted so whatever your linked list
looks like whenever you call add first
that element is going to be inserted at
the very head of the linked list or the
very beginning of the linked list linked
list also provides another variant of
the add method so there's one way to
just add the string element directly
because this is a string a linked list
you can also add it based on the
position so you can say add e at the
second position inside the linked list
so let's observe this output let me
comment all the code below line 18
because we will be using some more
methods here so we'll cover that in a
while but let's first understand the
output at line 18 if we run this program
so right click run as Java application
and this is the output we get so let's
understand the output or maybe let me do
this let me put this here one by one so
that we can interpret the output so I'm
adding two elements and printing the
list then calling add last and printing
the new list then calling add first
printing the new list and then calling
list dot add 2 comma e and printing the
list again so let's observe this outputs
one by one I'll comment this and let's
run this now
so if I run this particular program the
program till line 14 is executed because
rest of the code is all commented let me
comment this as well and if I run it
again yes this is the output I get so at
line 12 and 13 I've added two elements
and I print the list there are only two
elements and they are printed in the
fashion a comma B everything is good
here now let's uncomment this code and
now I'm calling add last method and by
adding an element with string C which
should be added at the very last of this
particular list so let's see now what
happens let me comment this one so that
we only see one list at the output
okay we see a comma B comma C so C has
been successfully added to the end of
the list now let's interpret this
particular method which is called add
first so I'm going to uncomment this and
comment the previous this out so now
there's only one sys out here so I'm
adding two elements adding C at the last
and now adding D at the very beginning
and printing out the list let's see what
happens okay so the D has been added at
the very beginning of the list even
before a so now it looks like d comma a
comma B comma C so far so good now let's
move to this particular code and now I'm
saying add an element called called e at
the second position inside this list
remember second position so let's run
this list now this program now so now I
see D comma a if you remember the
previous output was d a b c if I just
uncomment this for a while just to make
it more clearer and if I run this
program the previous list was D comma a
comma B comma C and the new one says d a
e e has been inserted at the position
two so 0 1 2 position 2 has been added
with this new string e and my list is
modified now it's time to find some
interesting operations about the removal
so what happens if I try to remove
elements from this list and then we will
observe the output again so let's say if
I say list dot remove B and so I'm
saying just drop this particular element
so you can directly specify that
particular elements value and that
element will be removed from the list
and let's see what output do I get if I
just call list dot remove B and I
comment the rest of the code we should
see a new output here which should not
have B so so running the program again
yes so this was the old collection and
this is the new collection from which B
is gone because I've called list dot
remove B now you can also remove
elements based on the index position
instead of specifying the element
explicitly you can specify the index
position and what happens if I call list
dot remove 3 Let's observe the output
here as well so I'm just going to copy
paste this is out and we'll see what
output do we get if we remove the
element at third location
okay so this was the previous output
after removing B and if I call list dot
remove 3 so 0 1 2 3 C is the element
which is at third location and it is
gone when I call list dot remove three C
is gone and D comma a comma e is only
remaining now let's try to understand
this particular line which says list dot
remove first expectedly this is going to
remove the element from the very
beginning so whatever element is present
at the beginning it is going to remove
the element and then we are going to
print the list the modified list so we
were here till d a e and D was the
element which was at the beginning and
if I called remove first D is removed
and now only a comma e is available and
now I use another interesting method
which is called list dot remove last and
then I print the list the modified list
so this is the list remaining and I am
calling remove just so e should be
dropped and only a should be left in
this particular list
yes we only see a here so this is
basically what I wanted to show you in
this program that we can perform
different kind of operations using
different methods like add add first add
last remove remove first remove last
obviously there are more interesting
methods available in this particular
class do check out the API documentation
for it and there you can see all the
different interesting methods which you
can use while implementing linked list
so this is all I wanted to cover in this
particular session and in the next
session we are going to cover an
interesting framework class which is
called set we are going to learn about
sets in Java in the next session let's
get started with half set in Java if you
remember I covered in the collections
framework session that hash set is part
of the set interface hierarchy and sets
have a property that they keep the
collections element unique if you try to
add duplicate elements to the a set it
will will not accept that and it will
still maintain the uniqueness property
of the collection hashtag provides some
additional features to the set which is
that in this case the elements would be
accessed in a random fashion they will
not be accessed in a fixed sequence
rather they will be accessed in a random
fashion hence the name has set so if you
read about this particular class in the
documentation it will basically cover
all the things which I just described it
also accepts null elements if you want
to insert null but why would you try to
insert null that's the first question
which you should ask it again provides
similar kind of utility methods to the
list interface collection hierarchy we
covered like some utility methods to add
the elements to remove the elements to
check the size of the collection and to
check if an element exists in the
collection or not etc etc and we will
cover some of these methods in the demo
this is again not synchronized so this
is not a thread safe collection which
you should know so let's look at a
demonstration of hash set and how do we
actually create a headset how do we
operate upon a hash set using different
utility methods so as you can see I have
created a class here which is called
hash set demo there's a public static
void main method and then at line number
10 you will see that I have created the
hash set and again it starts with the
concrete class here which says hash set
and you can obviously write it as set as
well which will also work fine so we
write the set type as string so this
particular set is going to hold only and
only string objects and nothing else and
this set is basically a type of hash set
again this is not mandatory so you can
remove that it will still not complain
and the program will run fine if you
want to specify a size please do that if
you do not want to specify the size
nothing goes wrong and it will be
initialized with the default memory
footprint but remember doing this wastes
a bit of memory so if you are running
this program on a machine which is
really tight on memory always put some
kind of initialization size based on
your knowledge of how many elements are
going to be stored in this collection so
after that at line number 12 we start
adding elements to this collection and
for adding the elements the method which
is provided by the hash set class is ADD
so you use the add method to add new
elements so at line number 12 line
number 13 14 and 15 I use the method
again and again to add some elements If
You observe the line number 14 and the
line number 15 these two lines are
adding the same element so I'm trying to
add C twice to this particular hash set
and we will observe the output to see
what happens if we try to add duplicate
elements in the hash set because if you
remember the sets are supposed to be
unique they should not be stored during
duplicate elements that's the property
of sets so that's what I demonstrate by
by adding duplicate elements to see how
it behaves and let's do that let me
comment the rest of the code for a while
and let's run just this part of the code
where I add C twice and I print the hash
set and let's see what happens so I go
to run as and I click on Java
application and I only see three
elements even though I added four I only
see three and C has been added only once
not twice now you might be wondering
whether the C is the C added at line 14
or the C added at line 15. so to
understand that we need to understand
how hash sets add method works so this
add method is basically returning a
Boolean value if the element is added
successfully this ad is going to return
true and if the element could not be
added successfully this add method is
going to return on false so let's do
that let's store the result of these egg
methods let's call this R1 and let's
call this one as R2
okay and now we will try to print R1 and
R2 and see what happens so if we write
system dot out Dot println and I say R1
and then I just copy this after line 16
and write R2 and now we will observe the
output of these to see which when we did
the add at 14 and when we did the ad at
16 which actually resulted in C getting
added did C get overwritten or did C did
not add twice what happens
so we see that when we do the ad at line
14 we get true so it means that this ad
was successful and C was added here and
when I did the ad again at line 16 this
returned a false it means the hash set
rejected this add operation so this C
was not added so the actual C was never
overwritten the original C was
maintained and when you try to add a
duplicate value with the same value a
duplicate element with the same value
hashtag is going to reject that so that
actually proves that the set will
maintain the uh the uniqueness property
and it will reject all the duplicates
subsequently that was about the ad uh
property now let's understand another
interesting property of the contains
method contains method of the set class
is used to find if an element exists in
the set or not so you can just use the
hash set variable name dot contains and
just type the actual element and this is
going to return true or false based on
whether this element is present in the
hash set or not present in the hash set
if it is present then this contains
method is going to return true otherwise
it is going to return false so let's run
this method and observe the output at
line 21.
so it says list we are writing this
particular string which says does list
contain C or not and it returns true
because yes my half set does contain C
now coming to line 23 I use another
method of the hash set which is the
remove operation which you can use to
remove an element from the set and then
I'm again doing a sound and I'm asking
the to print the set this should be set
and not list
so then I'm checking if what happens to
my hash set if I call the remove method
and I'm just printing the modified hash
set at line 24. so let's see what
happens with the effect of remove
operation okay so after removing a this
is what remains in my hash set and a has
been successfully dropped if I call the
remove method and then I try to just
iterate over the hash set to show you
how does this iteration work it again
works on exactly the same way it has
been working for the list
implementations that on the rhs of this
column you write the collection name so
hash set and on the LHS of this colon
you write the representation of the
element so this hash set is going to
contain string and this is just a
placeholder it can be anything this is
just a temporary variable to store the
current value at the current step of the
hash set iteration and I'm printing all
the items one by one
so if I run this I am able to print B
and C because that's all which is
remaining in this hash set so this was a
very quick demo to show you the
functionalities of the hash set how does
hash set maintains uniqueness how do you
remove elements how do you add elements
how do you check for an element's
existence using contains there's also a
method to get the element of the hash
set if you want to so these are all the
different properties and methods
available in the asset and do check it
check out the API documentation of the
hash set to learn about more methods so
that's all I wanted to cover in this
particular session where we focused only
on hash set and in the next session we
will be discussing about three sets and
we will also see an example of how do we
Implement presets in Java let's get
started with three sets in Java so in
the previous session we talked about
about hash set which is one of the
implementation of the set hierarchy and
today we'll be focusing on preset and if
you remember when we talked about this
collection framework I discussed briefly
about preset that the main reason you
will use tree set is basically when you
want to maintain natural ordering of the
elements if you are adding your custom
elements then you need to tell Java how
to compare and sort and order the
elements but that's for another day when
we'll cover about the detailed
comparable and comparator interfaces for
now what you can understand that
whenever you have to maintain the
natural order of the elements
automatically then you should use preset
along with that the set property still
holds true that this tree set cannot
have duplicate elements we should also
know that reset is not synchronized so
it is not a thread safe collection so we
we remember be aware that whenever you
are trying to use preset in a
multi-threaded environment you need to
write more wiring code around it so that
preset works as expect affected okay
that was about a brief theory about the
preset you can read about about it in
detail in this tree set documentation
class and with that let's switch to a
demonstration of the preset class so I
have prepared a class here which is
called reset demo as you can see it has
a public static void main method and at
line number eight I am initializing that
reset again it's again the standard
representation of initializing a
collection which we have been using
throughout the different examples of the
collections so preset of string so this
particular preset is going to hold only
on only string elements if you try to
add another element it is going to
through a compilation error and the on
the rhs I'm just saying new preset and
again this is not mandatory so I can
remove that and it will still work you
can specify the size whenever you know
about the scope of the collection you
should always specify the size for this
demonstration it's a lightweight program
so it's fine after that from line number
but 10 till line number 13 I'm again
going to add some elements and again if
you see I'm adding elements in random
order I'm adding B and then I'm adding
adding a then I am adding C twice just
to show you the uniqueness property of
the tree set does it still hold true or
not we will be able to figure that out
from this particular example and we will
also see if I am adding B before a will
it be printed in a fraction called BAC
or will it be printed in a fashion
called ABC we should also know that so
let's try to run this program and
understand the output
so if we look at the output we see a
before B but here when we added the
elements we saw B before a we added B
first and then we added a and then we
added C twice and as per the uniqueness
property of this set the second uh
addition statement at line number 13
returned false and set rejected this
addition because it could see that c was
already present in this particular
collection so C is added only once but
what's interesting is that b is added
first but B is added B is printed after
a so the natural order of the elements
in this collection is automatically
maintained by preset so what under the
hood reset does here that it looks at
the type which is a predefined type in
Java string is a predefined class in
Java so it will use its own sorting
algorithm to sort the strings based on
their natural order of sequence and in
the natural order of sequence a will
always come before B and B will always
come before c so it will automatically
apply that sorting and will present the
result to you if you are using a custom
class here let's say your own student
class or your own customer class or your
own account class in that case that
account class or student class or
customer class needs to tell Java how to
sort elements and for that you need to
write comparable and comparator
implementations which we will cover in
detail in the future sessions but for
now you you must understand that
whatever the type of class you are
specifying here should tell Java how to
sort the elements either Java should
know it automatically if it's a
predefined class like string or integer
or float or double then Java would
automatically know by default how to
sort the elements but if you are
creating a custom class of yours in the
three set and specifying that as a
preset type then you should also tell
Java how to sort the customers whether
you want to sort them based on your
first name whether you want to sort them
based on their age their salary Java
doesn't know that so you need you need
to tell Java about that if you're trying
to use a custom class as the type entry
set in this particular example I'm using
string here and it will apply the
natural ordering let's put C here in the
very beginning to see what happens and I
can comment this as we have already
maintained and verified that c is only
printed once and added once so I'm
adding C B A and let's run this program
I still get ABC because again the
natural order is implemented contrary to
this when we talked about hash set
remember I told that hash set is a
random access
element collection list so if you run
the hash set if you try to print the
headset again and again and again you
might see a different order sometimes if
I use a hash set here sometimes it will
print ABC sometimes it will print BAC
sometimes it might print cab any kind of
sequence any kind of random sequence it
will pick automatically that's the
property of hash set but in case of
preset no matter how many times you run
it you will always get the same order
based on the Sorting implementation
available in the class type so that's
all I wanted to cover about preset
please read about read about its Java
documentation in the API docs to
understand what all other methods and
utilities preset provides but it's
pretty much similar to what we saw in
the headset example like remove or get
etc etc and contains Etc so all the all
similar methods are available in the
three set class as well and that's all
we'll focus on on this particular
session and in the next session we are
going to talk about an interesting
framework called Maps let's get started
with maps in Java so first of all before
we understand this particular diagram
and the classes in this map framework
let's understand why do we need map so
there would be instances when you would
write a Java program or any kind of
program there would be always be
instances where you would need to store
a key value kind of arrangement a very
simple example can be that you want to
maintain a company database and you want
to just bring the whole mapping of the
employee ID to the employee name into
the Java program how do you do that you
need a key value sort of arrangement
where you can store the employee ID as
the keys and each of the employee ID key
would correspond to an employee name
which will be called the value so you
need a key and value arrangement in a
Java program to store that kind of
information and use that kind of
information in your program and that's
where map comes into to picture whenever
you have to store a key value
Arrangement remember you would always
think about maps maps should be the
right collection or the right data
structure to be used if you want to
store any key value arrangement in your
program so that's about map and here you
can see a nice framework representation
of map and this is going to be a
theoretical lecture where we will
understand how this map framework Works
what is the property and what are the
different implementation classes
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
foreign